All right,
we're on.
We're on live.
Yeah,
we're on live,
ladies and gentlemen.
Nobody even knows it.
A Justin Scoggins is about to fight.
There was a bit of a delay with a Callan and shop getting here.
Fast Airlines.
Southwest Airlines will let the fly every 15 minutes.
It's amazing.
They get it anywhere at all.
But uh,
it's sex bus get to fly everywhere.
Anywhere anybody at won't fly that.
They're like,
all right,
well cool.
Uh,
if you never heard this podcast before,
this is what we call fight companion podcast.
Um,
Scoggins this kid right here,
Justin Scoggins,
that's his name,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I called one of his fights before and he is about to fight.
The fight is going to start.
Mario Yamasaki says go now.
Fight starts now.
Um,
pressure.
Really interesting fighter.
He fights.
He's got like this karate style,
but he also,
um,
he also,
uh,
throws a lot of,
um,
like a traditional martial arts techniques and he's got a wrestling background,
so it's pretty interesting.
Oh,
it was getting dragged to the ground.
Look at this.
It's Goggins is the guy with their black shoes.
The guy on the bottom.
Yeah.
Dustin Ortiz,
Justin Scoggins and Dustin Ortiz.
Dustin came out,
pressure map,
take pressure on him right away,
which is pretty impressive because Scoggins a good wrestler.
If you never heard this podcast before,
this is what we call fight companion podcast.
What we do is we watched the fights live.
We're watching the fights lights four 15 on the clock right now.
Unless you want to,
if you want to sync up.
We,
we um,
[inaudible] I like how he scooted his hips up there.
That was some expert shit.
Oh,
it's sneaky.
We do these podcasts while the fights are going live and we talk while the
fights are happening and that's what we're doing right now.
Dustin Ortiz's on top.
Justin Scoggins is on the bottom.
Who came out with fight companion who let me know.
I Dunno.
Just happened.
It just kind of happened,
but it's a good way to call it.
Yeah.
And so a lot of people,
what they do is they watch this and they watch the fights at the same time.
If you're doing that,
look at these kind of,
Kinda need them in the face when he's down,
which is kind of a sneaky thing you can do,
right?
Can you do?
Yeah.
You kind of guys.
Oh,
we got it done.
It's going to pop.
It's going sideways to look at.
He's putting his foot.
Stop it.
He has put his foot on there.
That's pretty slick.
That's,
that's slick.
Slick,
but oh,
oh,
oh.
It's hyper extended.
Oh,
this is so ugly.
Damn.
That dude is gangster,
so,
so tough that he's not.
Wow.
That's amazing.
He got out of that,
but keep an eye on that arm.
That arm might be Jack Modified for sure.
Another word.
Yeah,
that thing's done,
son.
That arm for sure.
It's going to suck jerking off of that thing for the next couple of weeks.
You're going to have to play the mystery,
man.
You have to use the left arm.
Doug.
I'm going to get really weird.
It was his left arm,
wasn't it?
Hmm.
Oh they hell.
They said,
well wasn't it?
If he's left handed.
Right.
And then we'd have to go back over it again.
I'm pretty sure it was his left arm that he was attacking.
Yeah,
you're right.
Yeah.
Okay.
But uh,
Scoggins very high in this kid.
He's only 21 to wow.
And like I said,
wrestling background,
but real good at karate.
Is that a att?
Yeah.
These guys are 35 hours a one 25 the flyweight.
These motherfuckers go for days.
Wow.
Cardio is even in their mind,
they think about it.
They should have 25 minute rounds looking at 25 minute rounds.
Three 25 minute rounds there.
Hummingbirds.
Oh,
hand down.
Yeah.
I'll get this.
Scoggins takes his bag.
Very nice.
Good role by Dustin.
Dustin looks like more of a wrestler and Scoggins does it has a lot more
[inaudible] shoes yet.
So we're looking at is Dustin is not giving up man.
Motherfuckers on his back right now.
Ooo,
good trip.
So we just got back from Vegas to fights,
man.
Look at this or teases getting Scoggins back.
Scoggins fighting off those hooks.
He's going to spin it.
We'll get that.
So good.
This is going to spin trying to hit that switch the cages in the way cage fucks
you up a lot of times,
Huh?
Cage really limits a lot of stuff.
It can help you sometimes wait,
especially if you're a ground and pound guy wrestler grounded pound.
It's a dream for you.
But as a Jujitsu guy makes things tougher.
I think power Dustin or is a Duke Roufus has guy.
Very interesting.
That's why you so who is to Rufus?
How dare you?
How dare you ever do
I like asking the questions that a lot of people don't know.
Oh,
too bad.
We don't have like a way,
that's what I'm here.
If we had like a whip and they just slap Cowen.
How'd he says that?
How do you not know who Duke Roufus Scoggins dropdown for gt room.
The brother of,
um,
Rick Rufus,
Rick the Jet Rufus who was,
uh,
one of the big PKA karate stars.
Like one of the most exciting steps.
Yeah.
Amazing fighter who turned into a more tie fighter after we had some more tie
fighters and got fucked up.
And then his brother Duke after,
um,
his after Rick Rick up fucked up by some Thai fighters.
Um,
his brother went into a Meu time self and Duke became a more Thai world champion
and now he trains Anthony Pettis.
Sergio Pettis.
Wow.
He's trained a Alan Belcher is trained a lot of high level fighters.
Any trains.
It's got Dustin our teas too.
He was on my podcast last week,
two weeks ago.
Great.
Really good guy.
Really good salt of the earth.
Yes.
Couldn't get a nicer person and super like super intelligent and really well
read.
Uh,
when it comes to fighting,
she knows everything about Moyie Thai especially on TV.
Lot of empty seats out there.
Yeah,
the crowd.
Well this is the,
one of the first fights,
uh,
of the second card of the second day and they're in a 14 seat arena.
If you're a UFC,
UFC fan,
you are just just in your pants for this weekend.
Yeah.
Listen,
there's no big,
but look at me.
Right.
And have you ever seen me?
This I've one lazy eye.
I'm exhausted.
Just got off the plane straight to Rogan studios.
Exhaust nowhere to go and UFC.
What?
I mean,
it's been Yossi 20% I'm like CNN of UFC right now while I was out drinking with
mark de Gras,
Tay,
Brian Cowen,
Brian Stann,
my buddy Justin,
and we were out until four o'clock in the fucking morning.
I had to get up at seven and cash.
How late it was.
Well that's Vegas man.
Everybody's at four o'clock in the morning.
The places mob and also they sent,
the casinos are set up so you don't realize how late it is.
There's music,
the lights,
Dustin one nice left hook there.
Look at this.
Boom at the right hand and then taking him with the left hook of this call.
Ooh,
that was after two days in Vegas though.
I'm good.
You can keep it.
You get a human being.
That's my thoughts.
Exactly.
Two Days in Vegas is all you need.
Some dudes love it there,
man.
I know.
So gamblers,
look at how Scoggins style,
man,
it's really interesting style for a guy who was a good wrestler.
Put works interesting for sure.
It's all karate.
He's very like Mochida like look at that.
But he throws a lot of front lake sidekicks.
Almost like a point.
Your style,
Dustin aren't teases.
No joke though,
man.
Not at all,
I'm just bringing it.
I love that Leprechaun beard too.
Oh,
bulletproof coffee.
Both guys podcasting it a lot bolder with this dog has with a beautiful tie up
of that cause he's like got that right arm hooked.
Like he's going for a crucifix here.
Someone almost got a crucifix this weekend.
I forget who it was.
Someone rolled into a crucifix.
Did the same thing.
Tied up one arm when my faves raw Drysdale got a rear naked choke.
First round.
Did he really?
Yup.
First fight of the night.
Not Surprising.
Drysdales a monster.
All I know is I got to hang out with Dan Severn.
Um,
the beast.
Yes.
He looks at his skin's better than anyone's in the bedroom.
Sat 56 years old.
Couldn't look better.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Right?
Was he drinking fucking raw milk all day?
I,
yeah,
I'm somewhere.
He looks like a muscular Freddie Mercury.
He's a great guy too.
He's got some great stories about the old wrestling days,
international wrestling.
Louie this or tease roles,
Dustin over right in front of Rufus.
The other thing about having a coach like to crew is,
is he's such a great guy that like he motivates you so much.
You want to fight well,
want to win for me.
Yeah,
that's real man.
You know guys talking about their relationships that they have with their
trainers like that.
Me and Dwayne or time I had breakfast with Dwayne and and Vegas retirement that
him and Tj,
how close they are and oh,
you're seen.
For him it's cool because it's like he's living through Tj.
Like he wished he had himself as a coach when he's coming up.
So for Tj it's cool that is dead is interesting.
Like it takes a lifetime to knowledge
and a lot of times by the time guys did their,
their bodies are worn out.
Yeah.
It's crazy that a teacher had no time to bask in the championship.
He just got back right back into camp.
I don't like that.
Like after I was talking to Tj battle,
he goes,
I'm right back in the canvas already,
man.
You just won the belt is yeah,
that's what they want,
man.
That's it.
All right.
Well,
you know,
um,
it was supposed to be in Vegas.
It's supposed to be,
uh,
August.
The late August show was supposed to be in Vegas and something happened.
They decide to move it to a Sacramento because it's t J's hometown.
Good for Tj.
Yeah.
Great for Tj.
Terrible for brow because of the quick turnaround after a k o that's the only
thing that concerns me.
But why rush it like this?
That's a good question.
Browse camp wanted it.
They wanted it right away.
They think it was a fluke.
No,
no homie.
A fluke is if you get hit right,
like in the first round,
get knocked out.
That's a fluke.
Yeah.
They don't live rounds of a pure ass.
Wilbon is not a fluke.
They think the five rounds came about because of the first round.
Cause he clipped him.
He got dropped in the first round.
He didn't know where the fuck you was for the rest of the fight.
Oh Wow.
Like he went into the fifth round apparently,
and he thought it was the third round.
He had no idea what was going on.
I get that.
How that that,
that,
that speaks to your point about having them fight that early though he needs
more time off.
Oh yeah.
That's a head trauma man.
But the,
you know,
those Brazilians are tough as nails,
man.
They want,
they want to kill them.
Falter,
you know?
Yeah.
Justin Ortiz is strong as fuck dude,
look at this.
Meanwhile his pressures Coggins unbelievable.
Scoggins is like this kid that has a lot of hype behind him and justifiably,
but I am blown away by Dustin Ortiz.
Right.
I mean that's just the fact that he got out of that arm bar man.
Then our bar was fucking,
it was his left arm.
You're writing this on the replay was his left,
was it?
Yeah,
you're correct.
So maybe jerks off lefty.
We don't know.
Maybe it makes it up.
Could be ambidextrous.
Maybe just gets a cortisone shot so he could keep eating off.
She's flexible.
You might use or might use both.
Finds a doctor,
give them cortisone shots and continue this jack off.
Uh,
can we,
uh,
you almost got caught in a bad situation there and instinctively shoved that
second Armin Scoggins
is fishing for the triangle ground and pound stuff.
If,
especially if you're a restaurant like this where you had a wrestling base and
you're heavy on the sky,
like a Mark Munoz,
it opens you up for submissions.
Huh?
What are you saying Brian?
This guy and in the little box here,
I saw him leaning against the,
uh,
do you know who that is?
No.
How dare you again?
Yeah,
that's Marcus Conan's.
So here he is such a stud that is a fucking legend.
He was one of the heavyweight champions of extreme fighting championship.
He was a part of one of the fights that changed MMA.
Really?
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
he fought Maury Smith and Maury Smith head kicked him and nobody amber from
Denver.
Wow.
Nobody at Maurice's from Denver.
Yeah,
yeah.
Originally.
Yep.
Okay.
And he trained at a Seattle though,
right?
Did most of his,
he lives in Seattle now.
Random,
some Maurice this weekend at the lion fights.
Really?
Yeah.
Muy Thai fighter.
How's
he look?
He looks great.
Really fucking just fought.
Is 50 just bought?
Yeah.
He one head kick.
At 50 50 oh my God.
How to fight.
Who did he fight?
Some guy who shouldn't have been fighting.
Maury Smith.
Yeah.
Some guy.
The story and it's taking me some guy,
Guy Murray Smith beat the shit.
Tell me about,
tell me about Conan and the fight.
Oh,
I'm so,
Conan was a Jiu Jitsu black belt and that was back at the time when everybody
thought that Jujitsu black belts were like unstoppable.
Like if someone was a Jujitsu black belt,
it was it,
you know,
you were just getting killed.
It was like the hoists Gracie days,
the early days.
It was like 93 94 somewhere around there and Maury Smith leg kicked the fuck out
of them and then head kicked him.
Wow.
Yeah.
It just kept the fight standing when,
when he got taken to the ground,
use good butterflies got back up to his feet.
Just really never Morris his ground game was all about defense.
100% defense.
It was all butterflies and defense and endurance.
Maurice has crazy,
crazy cardio for a heavyweight did.
Yeah,
I remember that fight with Mark Coleman.
I remember that so well.
Just kicking them going,
what's up?
Come on.
Ground up,
Cami.
Mark.
Mark Coleman.
That's what he said during the pre fight.
He was like a more ground and pound the shit out of them.
And so I was there,
man.
I was there live.
Yeah,
I interviewed him after the fight.
That was back when I was the post fight interviewer and Maurice was standing in
front of him.
He goes,
come on mark ground and pump me.
Come on mark.
Black leg kick.
Come on,
mark.
Just talking.
I'm like,
come on.
Ground up on me.
Come on.
Ground up.
Tell me whack.
Whack him.
What's that leg kick?
Yeah,
you're gangster.
but he was,
he's not an Morris is an interesting guy because he's not like an angry guy
though.
He tried to,
you know,
like mark was done.
He was so exhausted but more.
He's never like tried to close the deal.
Never tried to finish him off.
Just fought real smart but was fucking with him.
I'm beating his ass.
Some guys are like that.
Right guys was real nice personalities.
Like when you look at like a pack,
Ya'll just want to hurt anyone.
Maurice,
he's like,
he loves to play around like he's a silly goose,
but Conan just looked like I was watching him as you were taking pictures and I
looked at him and he's so wide and he looked like just an old like lion with
barnacles on it.
Just sitting there.
Not Sonya,
just,
no,
not at all.
He just looked like,
come back on us there.
Are we still recording?
Yeah.
We had a little computer issue.
Lays in jail is,
are we still on Ustream?
Yep.
Okay.
We had a little issue.
Oh,
Dustin.
Archie's with nice to left.
This is a great fucking fight.
This,
this isn't.
Meanwhile,
we're talking about all sorts of shit from the past and Scoggins and Ortiz who
won a war on a crazy fight.
Oh,
back here.
This is a great fight.
Scoggins takes him down again.
Hey Brendan.
Thanks for making me do a wheel kick in my genes this morning at 10 in the
morning.
That was a lot of fun.
If I'm a bunch of people,
that was good for the man.
That was someone else's idea though.
That's real good.
I have to hold the thing we talked about.
What was good about it?
Nothing.
I thought Kendell Xian blows Asil out though.
In this case,
Zachary's jeans.
Jeans are super.
How do you strike a,
how often you throw kicks?
Like once a year.
I would say since I've been boxing,
I kicked the bag now,
but no,
nothing like that.
I don't throw wheel kicks.
I had no business doing that.
Norm had norm.
Yeah.
Had An artichoke boy
stuck in half guard though.
Very hard to finish from half card.
Do it for me.
This Dustin rolls over.
Oh,
Scoggins stays on him.
Unbelievable fight.
This is why I love little guys,
man.
They just,
the transitions.
I love it.
You don't see heavyweights moving like this,
which I was little.
I was talking to on the way here.
He goes,
no you don't.
It's good to be the king of the beach,
bitch.
I would care about the beach.
The beach you say?
Yeah.
He say that.
Meanwhile,
sitting next to you are wedged in,
in those little seats on southwest.
I wish you were a smaller,
have you ever thought about trying to go to two oh five yeah,
I have.
Yeah,
I've thought about it before the end.
Towards the end of my career,
I'll do it.
I'll do one cut to it.
Just,
you know,
like everyone seems to do that.
It's like the older phase of the guys,
they didn't make the cut,
but um,
yeah,
I mean,
as right now I'm 250 pounds,
so that's a really tough cut.
Everyone always asks me that though.
You're about to 30 fight week though,
right?
A two 35.
So when you think about that,
you're not watching your diet at all.
I mean,
you're eating healthy,
but you're not like,
think about some of the shit that some of these guys do.
Like,
um,
you know a guy like Weidman.
Oh,
what does widen and walk around it before he tries to make two oh four or
[inaudible] 85 85 is a big fucking guy.
Yeah.
He is.
Well this is the difference.
A lot of those guys get crazy out of shape in between fights like crazy out of
shape.
I don't,
you know,
like I,
I don't,
I don't put on tons of weight.
Who puts on the most weight in between fights?
Well you used to be rumbled Johnson.
Yeah.
Anthony Johnson.
Just understanding like it,
he was walking around at two 35.
He's sucked down to one 70 and I,
we were doing this movie and I looked at him,
I said,
what do you weigh right now?
He goes about two 35 I said,
you're going to make one 70 and in two months he goes,
I'll make it.
Six weeks is fucking madness.
This fight is awesome.
We should really pay attention to this.
Like,
cause it's so good.
It's really good.
It's a crazy scramble.
Yeah.
Dustin Ortiz is no joke man.
He's on the map now.
Win,
lose or draw.
He's on the map because this is a great fight.
I like how this guy's protecting his knee because Dustin new.
Yep.
There you go.
Go for the knee bar.
Who did that?
Beautiful.
How are you?
Yeah.
Nice.
And one up on top and wash his legs fresh,
Ryan.
Man.
Yeah.
Well he's strong or tease is very strong.
This is great stuff we'll use covering Scoggins face.
That's a sneaky fucking move,
man.
You know we were talking about this the other day,
that Brian Caraway fishhook incident.
That's dark,
man.
This that's
dark.
That's frowned upon.
I can't leave how bombs he held that fish.
It's not by accident.
Come on.
Who?
I think you said it was a genuine accident,
right?
Well that's what he said.
You know,
I don't want to call him a liar,
but I think I just did.
Yeah,
he for,
she liked Careway.
I like him a lot.
I mean he might have not even known he was doing it because it was so ferocious
in the heat of the moment,
trying to finish that whole,
that's a crazy fucking row.
I'm trying to be nice.
I know
I was a straight straight elementary yard fish home pleat,
total fish hook.
How long did he hold it for?
Five seconds more maybe.
Right.
Just yanking him back baby.
Five seconds solid.
But I said yeah,
like five seconds is a long time for anything.
One,
two,
three,
you know that's long,
long time and he's got his fingers deep in this guy's mouth and he's pulling
them towards him to try to get the choke playing for keeps I,
they really do in a purge like commercial and one of my best friends,
Frank Grillo.
Did you see purge one though?
Oh of course I didn't man.
I kinda like it hurts one day.
One started.
I can't wait.
It hurts when it started,
it started,
I think they made the movie for something really tiny like,
like everybody,
like I'm $1 million they spent,
it was too much so popular that Ethan Hawke made $7 million on them and that's
why you blowing up Ethan Hawke spot.
I'm just telling you what he made.
People are going to hit him up for loans now.
I need some cash.
Yo Ethan.
Man,
I have this independent project.
How many guys come to you with like independent projects?
Three a day.
Including emails.
You get it to Joe?
Yeah,
I get dudes want me to help.
Help them produce their animated features and the Meta features.
Animated things,
movies,
TV shows.
Good friend fucking gave me an ear beating a ferocious ear beating the other day
about some reality show he's trying to put together about him being,
you know,
you're in the TV business.
I go,
well how many of the TV,
but what the fuck are you talking about?
What does that mean?
We had that TV show,
man.
You know you're in the TV business.
I,
I'm trying to put together this show.
Well find somebody who actually use it like a TV producer.
I want you to help me connect me.
No,
I don't have time.
This is the dose we,
me and you guys.
No one hits me up about doing that stuff.
I get Dick Pics.
That's what I do.
Take pics on Instagram and Twitter.
I get long volume.
Tough man.
Get some volume here.
Jamie.
Want to hear the ones,
I think you're gonna through your boy on the Ra.
Oh.
But that you have to Dustin.
Wow.
He just brought the pressure man.
Take uh,
Dustin or tees with the split decision.
Solid B.
Wow.
Scoggins is very bummed out,
man.
Of course.
Wow.
You know what?
We were talking so much,
we didn't really score that.
That's fair.
I don't know if it's fair.
I'd have to watch that fit.
You're talking so much.
I always say that like eat sometimes during a fight,
like while we're doing commentary,
like I talked about it with Jimmy Smith,
last stuff.
I companion when you mother fuckers weren't around.
Wow.
Doug Smith.
Great.
And uh,
Ian Mccall was,
I was on it too.
It was really fun.
But Jimmy was talking about they make him score it Bella toward,
they make them score the rounds.
Oh,
that's dope.
Yeah.
But they make them score the rounds.
Why?
He's doing commentary and I'm like,
man,
I don't know.
I don't do it.
Me Personally,
I could do it,
but I don't want to do it.
I say it during the pot during a broadcast,
I say,
you know,
I think this guy won the fight or one the rounds.
But the reality is if you want to really call the fight correctly,
you have to shut your mouth.
You're still scoring at boxing lives,
right?
I mean well it's a 10 point must system but it's,
it's,
you know,
it's really dumb because you're working within a flawed system.
Right.
But the real problem with that flawed system is like a boxing wrap around in
boxing it's three minutes and there's a bunch of them.
You know,
regular fight is 10 rounds,
non title fights,
10 fuck around.
It's tied to fight is 12 rounds.
You know,
an MMA fight.
Big Difference.
Three rounds,
only three rounds.
And there could be a ten nine round where one guy just beats the shit out of a
guy and then another ten nine round where it's like a toss up.
That doesn't make any sense cause it sucks.
Cause this is a sports so new too well stole a system.
We stole a of a judging system from boxing
because there just isn't a criteria for if somebody's keeping pressure on
holding position on somebody
take down,
take down defense.
How about takedown defense?
How about that?
That should go along with how about submission?
Attempting temps.
Yeah,
all that stuff and there should be like us
gale of like one to 10 of how close to submission is like the,
okay,
like look Scoggins and our perfect example.
That was a fucking nine that Armando was nine nine,
nine and a half.
That was about as close as you can get to not getting tab.
You have to take that in consideration.
Yeah,
he got out of it.
Look,
it's not mad at her at all.
I heard 14 bro.
No,
whatever.
She saw 24 she's already tattooed up.
I can't believe she can't be 14 that's not illegal.
I'll tell you what.
It was fun though at the expo.
Oh,
I'll tell you what.
It was so violent.
The questions I was getting about our Lawsky all that was amazing.
We were in the elevator.
Exhausting,
man.
Dude.
What happened?
Although I had human and I do this,
then I'm finally out of there.
I'm like,
all right,
this was a good day.
This is fun.
Last interview.
Um,
I go on some show,
I'm not going to call them out.
This dude,
I've had an issue with them before.
I did not want to do this radio and need because of this.
So I do the interview and he goes,
you haven't had a fight was awful.
That's sucked.
Excuse me sir.
You're 300 pounds.
You've never fought in your life.
You can't talk to people like that,
man,
I will never come on your show again after he critics to say that to him.
Oh,
when we were done,
he's like,
listen man,
I'm gonna give him,
don't bother.
Do not bother,
man.
I was like,
I'm good.
You know what I mean?
I'm,
I,
I don't,
I don't like confrontation.
So I just go,
I'm good man.
Just walked away.
But it's crazy to me.
Crazy to me,
man.
I thought it was terrible.
I said,
that's fine.
Who did you have winning though?
Use?
Oh,
you for sure.
One that I go,
thanks man.
You know what it is,
man.
It's,
it's that sports guy radio bullshit.
There's a certain amount of sports guy radio bullshit that's leaked into MMA.
You know,
like that.
They think that they can be cool.
Well,
there's no repercussions there.
You can talk to me however you want.
I can't do anything.
I'll get in trouble.
Obviously I'm not going to snap your neck.
I'd love to.
I'm not going to,
I can't do anything.
Yeah.
Well even nine that it's just like,
can't you talk about a fight without being disrespectful to the guy that was
fighting?
Like it seemed like you guys knew each other.
You were both very tentative.
It was.
There was a lot on the line for both of you are lost.
You look particularly nervous.
Like,
like what was,
what was frustrating about the fight?
Do you could talk about a fight for sure.
Look,
anybody whose ever competed before,
if you've had more than a few fights,
there's going to be some that are just go off.
You might be sick,
you might be injured,
you might,
I,
you know,
you,
you can't think that every fight is going to be great.
They're just not going to be,
you're going to have shitty ones.
Things happened in like,
but the thing is when I talked to him,
I was like,
Gabby on the AIO did that fight suck 100% should I have one?
Yeah.
Do I need to do things different?
Yes,
I was,
I was banking on just like I'm used to when I used to train with them an
aggressive or Lassi,
which I,
I hate that we're talking about again,
ally were just,
shit happens,
but our last scheme would come forward,
aggressive,
so worked on and I'm a back foot counter fighter.
It's how I get my takedown.
It's my big combination stuff like that.
So when he's not being aggressive and approaching,
I should've adapt and I didn't.
So you get a shitty fight and that's what happened.
Straight up fight sucked.
However,
I won the fight.
So this guy,
when you were doing this interview,
was he like mocking you?
Like,
what was he doing that was pissing you off so much?
No,
listen,
uh,
officer,
I could take his job if I wanted to on,
you know,
I just destroyed him on air w with everything,
fight,
talk,
everything.
So he was a little defensive already and I'm like,
yeah,
minute fight suck.
So it gave him a chance to jump in.
A fight was terrible.
Oh,
so before that,
oh,
so there was like a build up already where he was like kind of a like a little
bit and then I've been told him and then he was like,
well,
what's next for?
I said,
I haven't,
I have no idea man with this is a weird fight.
You know what they're going to do with me?
I don't know because technically I really,
I won the fight.
They gave our last game,
main event against big foot.
So obviously they're not too mad at him.
So with me,
I'm not sure.
I said,
who do you think I should fight?
And he had,
he had,
he couldn't come up with anything.
He had nothing.
What did you think about this truth situation,
man?
That's kind of crazy.
Math heartbroken.
I was looking forward to that fight and honestly I think it was almost a,
I don't say a blessing in disguise,
but I don't think she would have won that fight.
Really.
You're,
you're off.
I don't why?
I don't at all.
And I think that the time away they wanted to give him more of a,
an easier fight.
A guy where he could get his bearings back,
get used to the octagon and the lights.
It's a different animal.
And when you don't fight in while for those at your own calls him out
clean would have happened if you want to.
No,
go ahead.
You got this done for folks who don't know what happened.
Um,
Stephan struve is a really tall fighters foot
skyscraper.
They call it jet seven feet.
And uh,
doing well in the UFC has some pretty big wins and then all of a sudden he has a
heart condition,
like a serious,
legit heart condition.
They don't know if he's ever going to be able to fight again.
So he,
um,
take some time off.
I don't know what they did to try to fix his situation.
Surgery.
He had surgery on his heart.
Oh my God.
It's surgery with these valves and stuff.
Crazy stuff.
Fuck in his home town.
He had to get,
he had to see like all these doctors before one was like,
yeah,
let's do this.
So anyway,
um,
he has his surgery.
Takes how much time off was quite a while.
Quite a while.
Yeah.
You're looking at more than a year?
Yes.
Oh,
for sure.
So he's off for a long time.
And um,
he's in the locker room getting ready for his fight and his heart starts beating
like really fast and he has like an almost fainting spell,
like essentially like his body goes limp and they go,
yeah,
that's about it for you buddy.
And they,
uh,
they pull them off the card.
Like,
what's your gift?
An hour before you're supposed to do,
can you imagine if that happened inside the octagon?
They announced his name and this giraffe passes out and Kate's oldest magic
about what he's taking the steps up to the occupied just fucking Google apps is
seven foot.
No one's catching him son that's breaking area on his neck when he falls.
You know what I'm saying?
And you don't,
you don't want that.
That's happened plenty of times on a basketball court or somebody didn't live,
you know?
And so you can't,
you can't play around with has true big guys have a real hard time.
Those really tall.
There's a condition.
Yeah,
there's a condition and I can't remember the name of it.
Where,
where you know,
you just,
people dropped dead of a heart attack.
Well they don't live very long.
Oh yeah.
Little seven foot dudes.
Well he has two strikes against them.
One named the oldest fighter.
You know,
there's not a lot of grandpas out the cauliflower,
you know what I'm saying?
Or you know what I'm saying?
It's just not.
And then he's seven foot tall with a little numb.
I made that up.
I don't know if has a little numb,
but a little nub.
Ridiculous.
Yes.
And why did you say it?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Calm down.
It's already having a bad day
with a little nub.
So he's seven foot and he's a fighter.
So yeah,
he's,
he's on the back nine of life for sure.
That's the kind of insult.
The guy with a giant Dick just throws around [inaudible] got a little nub.
Just you called them a giraffe and now he's got a little giraffe is a perfect
way to describe him because he's so long.
Yeah.
Gangly.
I think metro would have beat him.
Really.
I do.
I think it was a horrible matchup for him.
Went cause we have the same manager and when they took,
he was telling me,
he's like,
yeah,
uh,
cause when I was looking for a fight before our last,
before the hunt fight fell off,
they're like,
Steve's going to be back man.
I'm like,
I don't want to fight.
The guy comes back from heart surgery.
Everyone's going to hate me,
man.
I don't want to exactly.
I'm like,
I don't want him to die on me.
I don't want to be known as that guy.
That's a good point because did you see adjusting gagey um,
Nick Newell fight?
I did.
I heard gates.
You just beat him like nick.
Dude only has one arm.
He's a one armed fighter and everybody's like rooting for him cause he's a one
armed paper hanger at KC kids.
A bad motherfucker.
He is.
He's an animal.
I started with gay,
well I gate g his first day in the gym I was there.
We had the same head coach in Denver.
He's an animal.
All American wrestler in the seventh at nationals bruise.
It strikes to Stryker and nick knows tough as shit,
but I didn't see the fight.
I don't date you like just manhandle him.
Right.
Beat him up to speed is yeah,
but it's like that's the weird thing.
It's like you're watching a guy beat a guy up who has one arm and noodles.
Uh,
you know,
it was very tough is no,
no doubt about it.
And it was very good.
He's very tough.
Now let's,
let's say you've never seen them before and you're like flipping through the
channels.
Like,
oh,
check it out.
MMA,
hold up.
Yeah,
this guy has one arm getting his ass whooped.
What does this make a wish?
You know what I'm saying?
Like this isn't cool.
And then again,
if a guy with one arm beats you,
that's even more of a mind fuck to you got to beat by a guy who was one fucking,
I remember when in high school we would wrestle guys.
Sometimes we were deaf or blind and there's always an interesting thing that's
different.
I had a buddy,
he thought he was going to be the next Frickin uh,
you know,
wrestling all star and he got paired up with a girl and she beat him.
He was crying classic.
Well def does Shawnee.
I wrestled a couple of guys who were deaf and I wrestled a couple of guys who
were blessed differently.
Yeah.
Death.
They can see you grab a hold of you.
What are know,
how's he defend headquarters?
A good question.
It's a very good question.
You know,
there's a dude is like the best pool player in the world who's deaf and when he
plays pool with turns,
his hearing aid office wasn't near Shit.
You can talk all the shit you want.
It goes into a zone and just fires.
He,
that's an advantage
to me.
So was saying with wrestlers at least like they can't hear themselves breathe,
which,
which has deaf wrestlers because I never thought about it has good or bad
effects I guess a good effect in the terms of it's not,
it doesn't get freaked out.
Yeah.
Don't freak out.
You don't know your fatigue on to something because when I listen to music and I
do conditioning,
I'll just going to say the music,
I take it off.
I'm all,
Dang,
I'm dry.
Even son,
I'm about to pass out,
put the music back on.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm straight.
But when you're running,
listen to music,
you don't realize how tired you are.
You just sweat and you feel good.
Yeah.
I think that you get better cardio point when you,
when you have the music change.
Matter of fact,
I've seen the clinical study where music does help your endurance,
stuff like that.
I said seems like it would.
It seems like good help you live.
You're doing like strength and conditioning workouts.
It seems like it would really,
the tiger guys on a loop downtown to his eye of the tiger and I batch by batch
hard.
You know the eye of
the tiger guy is the same guy that is the bud light guy.
Bud Light.
You remember that?
Those clearly,
yeah.
He would like sing it.
No.
Uh,
they would have like these funny things to you but like a to Mr. Kelly.
Okay.
Yeah.
Mr Couch Karaoke guy.
Yeah,
he would be,
he was a really nice guy,
man.
He was um,
he was the guy from survivor [inaudible] survivor.
He was with us on the maxim comedy tour when I did it with Charlie Murphy and
John Heffron.
Super Nice Guy.
Great voice too.
Yeah.
Real quick.
We got heavyweights up right now.
Louis.
Me,
when we were in the elevator with this guy,
we were in the elevator and he's easily chit giant.
Much bigger than you'd read and you were standing.
He's got fuck out.
King tattooed on his chest.
There you go.
It's kind of scary.
Really.
He was hanging out,
hanging out.
We were like,
what are you doing?
He goes,
I'm fighting tonight.
That's scary.
This girl's ass is scary.
This Brazilian chick,
good googly Mowgli.
She was,
they had international fight week,
so they had to like the Brazilian girls walk in
and someone needs a scrape,
some DNA off those Brazilian girls and Karen that here,
here,
I'll do it.
Cologne cross.
They can cross the desert when I'm loading up camera.
Heavy right hand from downtown.
Know whatever they have that grows acids like that in Brazil.
Please preserve it.
It's on,
want to go out like the Dodo bird.
[inaudible]
wonderful.
It's a mix of of Spanish and black and everything.
Well,
it's such a melting pot.
You know,
they had all the wrinkles girls.
I went into the green room and I was literally like fins the,
that little fans back there.
I have to shut him down.
I'm like,
just give me a second.
Literally trying to focus though.
How about this?
Um,
you know,
I change,
I have to wear a suit where this custom tailored suit to the UFC.
Boy Goldie.
Where's a three P's?
Guess where I change?
I change where the girls changed.
Ooh,
we're all buddies.
Boehner.
Patrol
professional is shit.
That's true.
You keep your eyes.
Do you think?
Do you think I ever don't flex when I'm in there?
You're never let go my gut and just stick it out like I'm pregnant.
I was just,
I was just in Mexico for three days.
We'll walking around the beach with no shirt on.
I,
my stomach hurt.
I was holding it in the whole time.
I doing everything I could.
I got to go.
If you hold it in,
it doesn't matter.
Hey Bro,
you don't know.
Look your,
you're packing.
I got a beautiful
Derrick Lewis has got,
uh,
yeah.
We should talk about the fights here.
Gutow you know,
sent day.
That's his name.
I don't,
I've never even heard of this guy.
Their,
yeah,
when he got no know heavyweights,
it's got some old school truck talking to Derek on the,
on the elevator.
No idea who he was like,
what's up bro?
How are you doing it?
Because Brian went,
stop fricking fantasize about as big as boss staring at him.
And I go,
I go,
are you a lawyer?
And so I said to him and he goes,
I'm fighting tonight.
I said,
I had a light heavyweight heavyweight.
Bryce said,
oh damn,
no.
You said,
well wait,
I got one 35 Brandon.
Good question.
Well,
like literally a foot taller than you let it just didn't know him.
What you need to tow then Brown Perry's Perry's and he's,
he's a legit six five.
No was he was,
he might be at sandals on a lot bigger than you.
Yeah.
Thicker.
Oh,
fucking with you.
Oh Shit.
Big Shot.
Brian's gonna fuck with him.
He needs to be careful of this guy.
You've got to be careful just trying to,
it's trying to get me fired.
Protecting him.
I'm protecting my friend from Derek [inaudible].
Last time you did this,
you know the last time you did this on,
on our podcast,
he started talking about Frank Mir and I went,
I and Frank Mir is one of my all time favorite fighters.
I love the challenge.
Love the guy.
I didn't challenge him.
You start talking shit about him and me and him fighting,
so I'm like,
I'd love to fight Frank Mir.
Sign me up,
man.
That'd be amazing.
It'd be an honor.
Sure enough headlines come out.
Shop wants to fight Frank Mir cars now because account and talking shit.
Push the buttons for sure.
Brendan,
how tall are you?
Six.
[inaudible] you're taller.
Oh,
Ken.
Derrick Lewis.
Yes.
Wow.
Six.
Three.
So shut your mouth.
Can a the toes.
You're almost already not or did he?
Uh,
I,
I didn't think so.
I didn't really know he did the count because he's black.
It.
Yeah.
Right.
Every person we walked like calendar like,
God,
that guy guy's tough.
I bet he's tough.
I went,
Brian,
if you're going to do that all day,
fucking UFC expo out,
bro,
Bro.
I was about to freak out.
We go in the green room,
there's Anthony Pettis and their joy.
Benevidez you know chuck Liddell.
Brian goes,
Bro,
there are some tough guys around.
No,
that's what he saw.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
beautiful.
Beautiful job.
In the transition,
Derrick Lewis cracked and when the right,
what's he doing with this terrible celebration that was like a donkey.
Oh my God.
Towards you is gone.
He goes,
just goes,
what happened?
And have been there.
He'd say bell.
Yeah.
Be careful.
He say belts spanning Brennan by him.
Just by him large.
It's doing the people line.
Yeah.
You don't even want to be in the same room as Cain Velasquez,
dude.
I like the confidence the same.
That's where you gotta go back to stretch my man,
Phil Baroni.
When he knocked out Dave Manet's like I'm the best of the best.
He was so fired up.
That by the way,
is one of the best ever knockouts.
True.
He pinned him up to the cage with punches,
kept him up with punches.
My name was out cold and Baroni was like literally keeping his body standing up.
A little story about Baroni.
I was even fine.
I was just a super fan and pride came to Vegas.
I've got all my money together to buy these bullshit tickets on my best friend
and they were taking pictures outside the Caesar's palace,
fade or Cro.
Everyone's there.
I'm in.
I got a boner and the entire time I'm so excited,
man.
I see.
Brony my boy liked him and he and I didn't want to take a picture of the broken
by boy goes,
hey man,
get a picture.
I'm like,
all right,
there's a line.
I go up to Brown at tap my story.
Go,
hey man,
you mind if we get a pic not mixed up.
Turns around,
gets in my face goes,
Yo Bro,
you just call me a prick.
Like nab not ask for a picture.
I said pick it was a Stuart and I still have the picture.
He takes a picture,
but he's staring off at like some girls ask and I'm looking at the camera and
that's the first time I ever met Phil Baroni.
Did you just call me a prick?
And I literally,
it was like,
oh no,
no stuttering and shit.
No Sir.
Phil Baroni in the house.
Man.
Beast Cain Velasquez areas.
Hm.
Hm Hm.
Size that guy up.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I've been,
I was around him all week here in the same room I was there.
I was like already do.
When you standing around that guy,
what,
what goes through your mind?
I just want what he has.
You know what I'm just like you want,
do you want to be that bad guy?
That's what I do.
When I walked,
when I walked down,
let me fuck that guy.
That's [inaudible] so glad you're so honest.
When I went to the uprights,
it's,
Oh boy,
what's he gonna do?
Fight me.
Sure,
let's do it man.
Here more,
more of this shit like fuck a EA sports book.
Fuck capable as fuck that guy.
I love the purge.
But you were just fucking around man.
You know the EA sports stuff.
Listen man,
my feelings got hurt because I'm not in the sports game.
So they asked him,
[inaudible] asked me when I saw it of it and I give my,
this is,
that's how I feel,
man.
I was like,
I think I sh I should be in the game.
And so,
uh,
you know,
I'm not going to say what I really said,
but you know,
I said some bad things about not being the game because my feelings were hurt.
But then I went and said,
hey listen,
finally kid fans,
tweet ea sports and tell him how much you love for me to be in the game.
So,
uh,
of course headlines came out,
shop says blank blank EA sports.
Well that's a problem with podcasts.
It's like you can take something that we say add a context over the course of a
long show fucking around and talking shit and having fun and you,
you know,
you joke around and you're like fuck this or fuck that.
And when I say fuck,
when,
when I walked like,
so there's a UFC party I went to at some club and who knows in Vegas,
right?
I walk in,
there's the table and it's Cain Velasquez.
And when I say that,
I'll walk in and say,
fuck that guy.
It's because I want what he has.
I'm not being disrespectful.
Fuck that guy means I've loved to fight them.
I want one.
He has and I worked just as hard as he does,
if not harder.
And hopefully you're going to be,
you'll see him one day across the ring and you can't have reverence for him.
So you got to know and hopefully one day he comes into a party and says,
looks at me and says,
man,
Fuck Brendan job,
because he wants to fight me.
That's what you want,
right?
Just
that's it.
That's all it is.
If it comes to Derrick Lewis though,
just just stay out of his way.
It's just a thing where you know when you take things out of context,
I know.
Oh,
I get so comfortable.
Like he hasn't boys were,
it's,
you know,
we're in this room.
It's all comfy at coffee.
It's all warm.
We're chilling.
We're all friends.
Got Mike's on.
I don't know.
I forget where I'm at sometimes.
Yeah,
it is what it is,
man.
It's one of those things you're having fun.
I mean to combine the two of them and they're like the professionalism that we,
this dome tone,
one shot from that.
Boom.
He's six eight oh man.
Six three Brian,
he slouches when he's six three standing tall.
Look at that.
It's got a t shirt of him himself.
Yeah.
He said he's been looking at cane for awhile.
A picture.
Everybody as Cain.
That's what he's saying.
So he's trying to set himself up for a title shot boy.
Okay,
hold,
hold.
I liked the dream though and it's good to have a dream.
Yeah.
You know it's good to have a dream.
You might want to wait a little bit.
There's a lot of guys kind of waiting in line and stuff.
I want to wait a little brat.
I want to homeboy.
Ouch.
I would be surprised if homeboy you got knocked out cause the bone to the two oh
five boom.
Real small,
heavy home.
Damn herb dean.
Him Love Herb.
You got to love the celebration and Blah Blah,
blah.
For sure.
Some emotion though.
Yeah,
right.
There we go.
Kid hits hard.
Got to give them that.
No doubt about that.
No doubt he's a giant.
This Justin though.
Every heavyweight hits is Justin is Justin.
If you don't have time for you,
anywhere in your head has ever been a heavyweight that doesn't hit hard.
Garlic,
a pillow fighting heavyweight.
What does affidavit Jolla doing?
What's gets here?
This shit up.
Crank that shit up.
I just picture him in drag.
Yeah,
he's that weird.
Can't,
can't not.
I'm not mad at him for that though.
No,
me neither.
I responded to it.
I respect them a little more volume.
Jamie.
I respect him more.
Nope.
I have to watch Bj Penn.
He's one of my favorites.
Oh,
how cute is he selling us on the fight right now?
I think he is.
They must be in some sort of a thing.
It's a combination of sweet science,
not God's.
I love it.
Well,
and we certainly appreciate your support now.
Wednesday night here on Fox sports on it.
You've got to golden boy for me.
Oh Oscar.
Like you'll see sweet.
It looks fantastic by the way.
He just got out of Rehab Man.
A lot of guys that have long box and careers start getting depressed and a lot
of them start seeking help with their dopamine levels using the wrong shit like
alcohol and cocaine and that will 100% BME.
Right
after our last year I was like,
I might need to check myself.
You'll be able to fight it to go to rehab.
You felt it.
Oh kidding me.
What it's going to be.
First of all,
him and drag.
You can't be mad.
He's looking up some dime piece.
She was like,
listen,
the only way you can hit this,
if you put on these stockings and put some lipstick on,
guess what I'm putting on some stock and some lipstick to hit that.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
she's rushing to and Russian stripper bitches and merchant wild man.
Whatever.
Mercenaries.
Who is the guy?
Where did we brought the girl up and she had her phone,
her iPhone.
She recorded the halls.
What?
What's the guy's name?
Recorded?
Everything he was saying.
Who's that shakes.
She kept it in her purse.
Oh God.
He had a TV show.
What did he say about Jerry Springer?
Let's all kinds of nasty stuff when he was having sex with her.
Hello man.
Damn.
This kid's good.
Super Cool.
Beautiful.
That Austin trout fight.
Look at God sad that fight with the kid.
Can we get your boxing boots?
The Austin Trout fight?
I don't know if you won that one.
That was tough,
man.
The trout fight.
That one right there that you just saw him.
Did you see him drop him?
But that was a close fight,
man.
And then all you do is see the highlights because he's fighting Floyd Mayweather
Knicks.
They made it seem like you just destroyed trout.
He definitely did not.
I would have to go back and watch that again.
I don't really want to see it.
Yeah.
And then Floyd Mayweather split a clinic on him.
It's too much.
I think too much.
He's too big.
He's too big for that weight class.
Canelo as you think.
Well to fight Floyd Mayweather at the weight they fought in.
He didn't because he cuts too much.
He's not fast enough.
He's not fancy enough for Floyd.
Yeah.
That's interesting man.
Floyd is fast as fuck.
He's also just so smart.
This is so smart.
Intelligence defense is the best in the world.
Yeah.
There's nothing like it.
I've only seen him hit once.
The only time I've ever seen him hurt was Shane Mosley.
Those the only time he got a little,
uh,
yeah,
that's true.
My tag them a little bit by Donna tag them.
They're rematching.
I don't care about that rematch.
I don't want to them.
I don't see it.
Every match their rematch.
You want to see it really?
I'm not into it.
Well,
I definitely want to see the Floyd Mayweather sugar,
Shane Mosley rematched.
You know what I mean?
That's all I meant.
Sugar Shane Stk.
Little Punchy,
punchy,
and that's what happens.
What happens if a few years back,
I ranted at Terry Norris at a boxing event and it was super depressing.
I hadn't seen him in forever and all of a sudden I see what is,
what's going on here with this guy?
Oh,
helping guys with the disability.
Jury's coming off of a war problem.
Yeah.
He builds champions.
This is a show.
It's all just strength and conditioning.
Everybody has to have astro turf now.
American muscle,
that's what it is.
A new series.
American muscle.
I will 100% watch that.
I will be into that for sure.
South American muscle.
How crazy is that?
Didn't say a word.
Then when that was there and I was just super into it,
you guys probably won't want that day.
I'll watch your watch.
Sure.
They have shows now about guys making pools.
My friend who came up with new with this,
by this show that my,
I told you that I've got an ear beating this weekend and this guy
trying to tell me how,
you know,
how can I make the show?
I'm like,
I don't fucking wrong guy to talk to you.
But he's like,
do you think it could be a show?
I'm like,
dude,
there's a show about a guy that makes pools.
That's it.
Yeah.
So anything's possible.
Not only that,
all those shows a hundred percent bullshit.
Like it's all scripted,
right?
Those pawn stars show not,
not pawn star shows the um,
the George source.
Then they fill those lockers up.
They set it all up.
There's a guy who,
uh,
got fired from one of those shows and he ratted them all out.
I'll tell you right now,
if you tell me team moms script and I'm going to freak out if pitchers getting
pregnant just for the show.
I'm about to freak out.
I love that.
Show me.
I guarantee you there are some girls out there that are young and dumb who would
get pregnant to be on TV for sure.
MTV,
if you think that made people not want to have babies,
it did the exact opposite these years like,
hold up,
I get more Instagram followers by getting pregnant and on MTV 100% blow your
load in me.
Well,
they're not doing it because they're trying to save the world.
I mean that I hate when they were just trying to let everyone.
Pixie is a serious problem this day and age.
Derrick Lewis and Gudo suntay.
How do you say in so slow?
I was just looking at Daniel core man,
his suit and there's no reason that you should be as tough as he as he just
looks like the ups guy.
What are you talking about?
Daniel Cormier does not look like the killer.
I mean please shut your mouth.
He does.
He's wide as a house.
He's not a,
he's actually in a suit.
He looks kind of like a thick guy.
Just small.
You're saying he's kind of small,
doesn't look like so amazing and such a killer and it has been so dominant.
It's just not what you,
when you look at them in a suit you're like,
well it looks like a thick guy.
I've seen a lot of guys like that.
You're so looking at her.
You're such a string guy.
That's so weird.
I still see a little Jiu Jitsu guy.
It'd be like would rip your Dick Conan Conan.
It looks like I'm,
you know,
like a monster.
You know?
What do you have any idea with core me would do to Kona.
I know now by no means a cock in the morning standing outside smoking pizza
place.
And what does he five maybe ten five 11 maybe.
I don't know.
I'll give him five 11 he's an animal.
Well you know what he is?
He's a world class athlete.
Yeah,
that's what he is.
He's in the mind of a world class wrestler.
Like that is something that has been never seems remotely nervous.
He looks like he's going to buy milk.
The only time I saw him nervous,
Frank Mir.
Really?
Yup.
And he even admitted it.
He admitted he had UFC jitters.
When you flat man,
he was like,
fine.
He actually talked about that to UFC jitters.
UFC jitters a real man 100% guess what he didn't have with Dan fucking
Henderson?
Holy Shit.
He didn't have him.
God,
he racked nobody's rack.
I thought it was an episode of bully beat down.
I was like,
oh,
cool.
Bully.
Beatdown.
Nope.
UFC preview preview.
Why did he pick him up and body slammed him like that?
Because he to Dan Henderson,
you bastard,
you killed Dan.
Why did he do that to him though?
Dan was all tan and shit and choke them unconscious.
Dan didn't even tap like a man.
They don't like Brad said,
couldn't better shape than anybody in on the political.
It was just so as tight as he got.
I looked,
I was grabbing his arms.
I was like,
are you ready to fight?
He's like,
I'm two weeks out.
Right Dan?
When guys wear three piece suits on TV,
I don't know.
It's like,
what are we doing?
You're going a funeral home.
I'm sorry.
They dominoes jackets and the whole thing and they got me the,
the collared shirts that are form fitted in the pants that are fitted to my legs
and all that shit and the jacket.
I wore it a couple of times and I'm like,
this is just too cool.
She's not you,
Huh?
I can't do it.
They didn't want to put your jacket on for this interview.
Put your jacket on for this part.
I'm like,
it's going to make it better if I have a jacket on.
Ridiculous.
It's not the three piece suits to formal man.
It's too much from behind me.
People in their underwear about to Shin kick each other.
You want me to wear a jacket?
Like I'm selling insurance.
I don't get it,
man.
I don't get it.
It's weird.
It's too weird.
It's a weird thing.
Our cultural desires to all have the same fucking outfits on.
If we're being serious or classy or doing formality,
I have a suit on,
so listen to what I'm saying.
I know what I'm saying.
Clearly I'm prepared for no nonsense.
Nearly fell.
Have a v neck on.
I'm playing grab ass.
Guess what?
I'm playing grab ass all the time then iron Mike productions.
Yep.
Oh my God.
Mike Tyson has his own production.
Mike Tyson most be bored as shit he's doing.
It's Wednesday and Thursday.
Wow.
I end Mike productions.
Interesting man.
Interested.
You see a show and he was doing Broadway stuff.
No,
no,
it was good.
I heard it was awesome.
It was all done with it.
They stopped doing it.
I think so.
Cause he's doing that bullshit promotion thing though.
No,
the fights.
But he's done well.
He's only got so many stories I guess,
you know.
I mean it's one of those things like,
did you guys remember um,
the defending the caveman who was essentially like a hot stand up comedy act?
And it was like,
I never know if he's made so much money on that.
Not only did he make so much money out of Michael Chiklis,
that guy from the shield,
he actually performed it for awhile.
He was selling it so other guys can perform it.
Like he had this act and guys would do it.
It was like he would selling it as a theater show and it was essentially like
kind of a hacky standup comedy.
It's still performed everywhere.
Still making a fortune.
It's so weird.
It's the difference in men and women.
It's definitive,
but it's nothing groundbreaking.
It's like,
you know,
I mean,
I guess it's probably well done if people enjoy it.
I saw it on Broadway actually think about it.
I thought that it was,
it was well written.
I,
I didn't think he was a performer.
He wasn't the,
I saw the original guy who wrote it,
do it.
And then,
uh,
and so then now he's just licensed it licensed licenses out to,
to other actors to scrubs.
Yeah.
But it's actually,
it's,
they have to have it from adjacently draws the distinction being hunters and
gatherers and when the differences,
when men go to shop,
for example,
they,
their linear,
they want to go get their genes.
They're going to find it and kill it and take the genes and leave women when
they go shop,
they want to touch things,
smell it,
that they'd go through it.
They're gathering.
Well then Alma chain,
there's a lot of truth to it.
Yes you are.
Don't you have a lot of feminine energy bro?
I liked,
I liked my leg,
my fashion man.
I like liked the Russian fucking grab genes from target.
All right.
Why did you look at my,
why'd you look at my crime?
It's in my face.
There you go.
You're like my Japanese denim jeans from target.
These are Japanese down the ship out from charges.
I buy 90% of my clothes online.
Really?
Yup.
How's it fit?
Cause you're not small dude.
You have no weird dimensions.
You do.
Well,
the reason I say no because cause you're like thick.
You know what I'm saying?
You're in shape.
Yeah,
I buy you can't buy this like regular sweatpants from fricking Sam's Club.
I buy things that are like certain brands that I could buy like lucky jeans.
I buy like lucky jeans but is too big.
Yeah.
I have a 32 inch waist,
so I buy like a 33 or 34 inch waist.
See,
so they took my legs nor on the planet,
by the way.
How's your snoring glass?
No,
it's pretty good.
I couldn't sleep when do your hunting didn't sleep for four days cause cause he
was about two in the morning and just,
I'm a little bit,
a little bit of snore myself.
I would do this to you.
I go,
I go and you and you go on,
stop for a second,
then you go,
oh by the way,
I got an interview,
I got a new mouthpiece.
You don't have to worry about that really.
So we can cuddle a mouthpiece.
It's amazing.
Fantastic.
A mouthpiece that presses my tongue down and keeps my tongue from falling back
in my mouth.
So you don't smell it.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
It's uncomfortable at first it feels you're gonna throw out like someone's
trying to put the dictum,
trying to deep throat.
My father's got really bad sleep apnea.
He's got to have like a mask and everything and yeah,
but that's what I'm trying to move void doing.
Yeah.
And then there's also a surgery that you can get where they take out your
tonsils in your ad.
Yeah,
it was a core.
You just keep snoring.
You go on with life.
All right.
Yeah,
but you know what,
dude say that as long recovery.
They also say that about the fucking nose thing.
I that the deviated Septum kept me from doing it for a long time.
I had it done.
It was easy.
Yeah,
it was great.
I mean my nose is a little sensitive,
but I was rolling six weeks later and I was breathing gray up.
Do you still breathe?
Great.
Cause my,
my surgeon are pretty good.
So good to my whole life.
I had a whack,
knows I fell off.
My surgeon was unsuccessful.
Well you probably went back to the gym like a week later and started getting
punched in the face.
I said,
you went back a week later.
I was rolling.
No punches.
You fell down the stairs and broke her nose.
That's five.
Yeah.
When I was five years old,
smashed my nose,
shattered it cement stare and from then on it was useless.
And then my whole life was wrestling,
martial arts.
I got hit in the face.
Who knows how many times I know I broke my nose.
It least probably 10 to a dozen times at least.
And then there's all this scar tissue build up and they take your turbinates,
they,
they trim your turbinates down.
They,
my nose actually got wider after the surgery because when he,
when he cut me open,
this guy was a real wizard,
he retired doctor Feinstein and in Encino and he put these like these uh,
form,
they'd be saw these things,
these plastic splints and shoved that.
He's like,
what is your main concern?
And I explained,
you know,
look,
I do martial arts and stuff and I can't breathe out of my nose,
all this different jazz.
And he's like,
you know,
we're going to open it wide.
We're going to really get in there.
And we got trimmed down at what's called a turban.
And so the system for things,
we're going to spread it out.
So he like cut me open and,
and took out all this scar tissue.
And I mean he showed it to me at like a plate of all the shit they pulled out of
my nose.
Oh,
it was incredible.
And then he stuffs these plastic things in that sort of wedged my nose open.
And then stuff,
these foam inserts,
I had the same thing but minus collapsed and he had to take a piece of cartilage
and put it under my nose.
So,
and this is,
I have garbage with a cut it out.
I don't know.
He had to put an extra piece and I'm telling you,
what do you mean you don't have to be for two weeks?
My nose.
Look my nose.
I looked like a pig.
Hold on.
I know Brian had a nose job,
those dry Brian.
But they don't take Cartlidge from other people's body and put it in [inaudible]
from Mike from must taking it from my nose.
But he said,
I didn't take up these cartilage and put it under your nose cause it,
I don't take cartilage from your nose and put it in your nose.
That doesn't make sense.
So they just showed the,
so they just showed the ultimate fighter where the hometown,
where they go to their hometown show.
When I,
this is funny,
when I was,
uh,
when I was on,
I just passing over my nose.
You for sure.
[inaudible]
I literally had to have [inaudible] class and they had to put it under my nose
was up like this.
As Patty,
if it's called,
it's called.
And I said,
is my nose is going to come back to normal.
He said,
it'll come back though.
They gave you a dick nose.
Your nose looks like,
and my nose a little more turned up then it was,
by the way,
you used to have a nice bend to my notes here.
Was this 1980 no,
19 1989.
[inaudible] 98 I think.
98.
Yeah.
Um,
there's,
it's a great operation though if you get it done correctly and it takes,
God mind didn't take,
but back then,
so they showed the ultra,
if I really go home town,
when I was the ultimate fighter,
this is how naive and stupid I was.
This how cocky I was back then.
So I had four fights made all the way to the finale will open up a fire.
They'd come to your hometown,
your training,
get ready for the fight and they go into like your,
you know,
your background,
your life,
stuff like that.
And my thing on there,
I was talking about how Roy Nelson,
who was a former world champion,
all these fights has never found anybody like me.
And that was my,
that was my comment.
I was like,
don't worry,
he's never finding when like me and everyone on mine,
I was like,
Huh,
fuck,
I'm doing a lot of skew.
He flopped frigging everybody.
I just didn't take that into account man back in the day.
I was just talking Shit on mine.
Yeah.
Well you talk shit.
But I love the fact that you admit that you talk shit.
Yeah,
we came to do man.
You gotta keep it real,
keep it real.
They should get back in there and fight that.
You're honest about the shit talk.
It is important.
It's important if you get to talk shit to be honest.
But let me see this.
This is the strain is Guillermo del Toro.
It was a really good book for like three quarters of the way in.
And then it became shit.
Right.
I wonder what they're gonna do.
But the apparently the whole time they were uh,
making the book for a mini series.
They were designing it as a mini series.
It's about vampires.
I hope they do a good job.
Anything with Vampires,
I watch you to vampires or zombies.
But I've preferred to be a vampire if I had to pick one.
I don't know if he had that about love me and monster movie.
Love them.
Farmers only this is offer a dude's trying to date checks,
but you have to have a farmer.
Like can I get on that?
Even though I'm not a farmer just to clean house with these farmer bitches,
just like,
listen girl,
I know,
I know you're looking for a farmer.
Just send her a Dick pics from Marina del Rey just on the Ocu.
And overall it's just cause all you all know,
farmer,
farmer farming,
San Bish,
farming sand and work on his farm in San and growing loads.
Like is there going to be repercussions is I'm not a farmer.
I'm trying to throw all these bitches on farmers only know if you're in the date
and farmers,
you know,
like maybe the girls are not just in the farmers are in a Dutch guys who like
farmer girls.
But is there like one farmer girl is just a beast on there and none of these
shitty pharmacy and get to her.
And I do.
I create a profile and they hate me.
Maybe they come find me.
Misha Tate looking farmer.
Yeah.
Right out there wearing mini skirts and high heels pushing the bay.
A horse to slot ass on a horse.
Some Jessica Biel.
Look at Pharma.
Yeah,
she's out there.
I'm going to sign up to a hundred percent there's someone like that do stand
about Minnesota and places like that.
The Jessica,
all bad chick picking apples.
He turns over.
Innocent.
Just has no idea what's going on.
Looks over her shoulder at you.
I was like,
oh,
hi Brandon.
Went to help make these apples drinking raw milk and eating apples all day.
Just trying to be nice.
Trying to be nice the whole time.
Okay.
So Eddie Gordon,
who is,
uh,
this is,
um,
Matt Serra's guy and um,
he's fighting out of Ray Longo,
scamp,
Matt Serra,
Ray Longo,
and then Diego Lema.
Who's a Douglas Lema.
Who's the Belo tore champion bad motherfucker.
That's his brother Daigle.
Demod Suffolk.
Good fights in the house.
Three rounds in the UFC.
We rounds.
I flew in with Bruce Buffer.
We had some interesting conversations about dating.
He was fun.
Was it really?
It's only a 40 minute flight.
How many times did you talk about Pussy and 40 minutes?
The entire fort for 40 minutes.
It was a Bruce and this stuff is interesting.
Have you ever seen the cover of fighters,
magazine fighters?
Only magazine with Bruce?
No.
Bruce would like lipstick all over his face,
like kisses all over his face and two hot rods.
He's got us covered ever to like champagne bottles.
Him.
I said Jamie,
Pella Shit.
Oh Shit.
I'm in the life.
Yeah,
it's um,
it's quite ridiculous.
Okay.
He loved people have been,
so you know,
someone that's definitely in fucked up if they get knocked down because he does
not jump in early.
Ed Levine comes into your back room and he's like,
you listen,
I'll be your ref.
You're like,
damn,
I better be on it.
I'm about to get my ass whipped.
If he's not,
he stopped the Alexis Davis fight the right time when Ronda had her out.
I agree.
100% can assign,
I'm just making a joke.
He's a great rep.
Yes.
Look at this.
There's Bruce two different.
Look at him.
He's got the glass look.
The girls kissing him.
He's got the two glasses.
Oh,
I love it,
man.
Bruce just doing the living La Vida loca.
That's cub Swanson.
If you scroll up,
you can see what it says about Bruce.
Buffer.
Scroll down,
scroll down now,
popping bottles,
kissing the models,
the secret playboy lifestyle.
Damn he,
and it's like a tell all of course.
All,
all,
but he just really all,
he doesn't hold anything.
I love it.
He told me,
Brendan,
why don't you get down to Malibu and we'll find some bitches.
All right.
Yeah,
that's exactly what he said.
That's strange choice of words.
Now I love it.
Eddie Gordon and Diego Lima.
Let's get to this because these are two good fighters.
Gordon's a Banger,
man hitting any coffee sharing.
Oh Man.
Looks like lean is a locked.
Oh,
he's tall.
He's very tall.
Oh,
Gordon cracked him again.
okay.
I'm assuming he has PR.
Oh,
Hammer this ringing it son.
I'm assuming he as good Jujitsu train with Matt.
So we cracked him with that opera opera because behind there.
Oh,
he's Lima's in big trouble.
Big trouble.
Okay.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh he should.
They should stop it.
You are so right about leaving the Levine cold,
so right.
Okay.
They'll get that.
Damn.
What a performance by Eddie court.
Oh Man.
That kid can cry.
I love that upper cut through under the armpit.
Who'd from the side see it.
It's so hard to get out of the way in which a nasty,
especially when you're against it.
Tom Henderson got knocked out by,
I mean that's how I got knocked out by Anderson man.
Good.
It's been rotten.
Wrong Fella.
Yeah,
he brought it,
planted it,
built a forest with it.
Cut The forest down,
made houses with it.
Hands on farmers.com right now walking around two 20 it's interesting.
I don't know Brian.
He definitely had a little bit of fat on his body.
He's
a little bit jiggling going on.
Sarah.
Very excited that we'd been over there.
Weidman was names,
Weidman,
motherfuckers,
a champ of the world.
How good did he look?
Awesome.
No one fucks up.
Machita like look at that.
Boom,
would that right here that appeared in the back.
boom.
Check this out.
Boom.
Oh Geez
that he is.
He is he hitting the back of the head there,
but if it's in head,
boom,
you'll see.
Hits him in the back of the head.
Yeah,
right there.
Boom.
Well that was kind of behind the ear.
I mean transitioning.
You're good though.
It doesn't matter.
You know,
they tell you that too.
They tell you that name transition you back.
They go.
If you're in transition,
you turn your head and you get held back in the head.
Boom.
These at least boom.
Now he's loud.
Boom,
boom.
Four that he probably shouldn't have,
but I think it was perfect.
Perfect,
perfect stoppage.
His arm went limp and when it comes to back of the head,
those head kicks.
When you think about a head kick,
your wrapping around,
your completely targeting the back of the head.
The thing is though,
like they said,
it's in transition to eat.
There's nothing to really do and I,
like I said,
they tell you in the back,
they're like,
listen man,
if it's in transition,
you're moving.
It hits you in the back of the head.
It's your,
it's on you.
Why in minute?
Anthony Bordain no last name.
Do you watch that show
what our case is shooting a lion.
This is Hercules.
The Rock is Hercules.
Yes,
he is hundred percent natural.
45 years old.
Never done a steroid and as low,
not 45
35 I think.
Shut the shut down the rocks making shit up.
I was not 35 years every bit of 40 something.
Oh No,
no,
no.
You're wrong.
Why do you say you're wrong when you don't know how?
First of all,
he's 42 dammit.
It's insane.
The thing is I don't even need to check.
It's weird.
Yeah,
you're always wrong.
Always wrong.
Pretty much always wrong.
I need give or take.
I meant 35 and guys,
what do we fucking splitting hairs are accurate.
However,
I just like being a,
what is the word?
Incendiary.
If you've ever ridden a motorcycle man.
Ah Yes.
A long time ago.
Never do you want to really,
really bad fuck yet.
Right?
Heels got damn commercials.
Looks like so much fun.
I know.
So dangerous though,
right?
If I just rode my bike through Venice and I was scared as shit.
Dangerous.
Dangerous because you can't move.
You can't like really bad.
They get out away from shit,
but they say you chances of crashing on your bikes like 99% the first year you
buy one.
Yeah.
Motorcycle biker was,
hey,
it's a matter of time.
You're going to crash.
Yeah.
It's just to,
how bad is it?
I saw a guy down there.
I just don't,
I just don't want to do it.
I saw a really weird,
he slid off his bike and hit a curb and hit his head.
Ooh.
Was that you saw it?
Yup.
Whoa.
What'd you do?
Anything is dead stopped.
I got out,
Jack them off,
jumped back in my car.
I got out fucked him is this it took his watch.
Drove home with his wallet in my pocket
and it's bad news.
Gordon's a beast,
man.
Oh,
I know how this guy in the left feels right now.
Losing the ultimate fighter.
Do you think your life is over?
I started
applying@monstersdotcomputaresumeonaftertheultimatefighteronmonsters.com what's
monsters.com?
It's where everyone's job search place where you upload your resume.
People tried to find you for a job.
Man,
I'm making that up.
I didn't do that,
but I felt like doing it.
Look at this very exciting not matter.
That ring card girl,
I didn't notice
that guy has got a future.
He's got a future.
They both do.
Yeah,
he does.
You're right.
Diego Luna has got a future too.
What does that what?
What?
Diego Leymah now what?
What does his contract say now?
He still fights in the UFC.
Yes.
He'll get one more shot.
You lose that one.
You're done.
Really scares fight I've ever had lose the Roy Nelson.
Then they tell me,
oh,
we want you to fight in your hometown.
No pressure hometown for I think four months later.
Who did you find Chase Gormley and beat the brakes off him and 40 37 seconds.
37 seconds in front of home crowd.
What's your next move?
You're fine.
I just like it was throwing like this.
I was so nervous.
I had no idea what I was doing.
So nervous man.
No most nervous I've ever been because I thought if I lost that I want to have a
career.
Just kinda true.
All that work kind of true.
Yeah,
it is kind of true.
There's that won the UFC is,
oh,
we're good man.
Has anybody ever gone from the UFC?
Gotten cut,
came from ultimate fighter?
Yeah.
Came back and like made a run at the title
so far.
Nobody,
right.
I can't think of anyone know who's like the best guy that's been cut and look
sensational.
And other organizations,
probably Anthony Johnson.
Well,
at one point named Mark Hart who Could Strike Force One and beat Tyron Woodley.
Yeah.
But he was in strike force.
It's still like in the,
the zoom for banner.
That's true.
Yeah.
Cause they owned them at the time I end game the title shot.
Uh,
and the second question Anthony Johnson got caught.
But that was mostly a weight issue thing.
Lloyd issue man,
I don't East but God damn did he look good?
Think about it.
When you get cut from the UFC and you move on,
especially a young guy,
I'm trying to think who does.
Well
Melvin Gallard just one.
But that's really his first one.
Did Gallard when he did win,
he missed weight though again.
We did again.
Yes.
It's frustrating.
It.
Oh my God.
Does that do not get any person when that happens.
So you lose 20% of it.
Oh the other guy gets 20% good.
So,
so interesting to see different guys and the different weight cutting strategies
and you know,
some guys believe in drinking distilled water and some guys say you shouldn't
drink distilled water like to trying to like read their body of electrolytes.
So it's easy to look at this.
Boom Gordon with the big right hand and power the um,
the idea behind it is that you rid your body of all these electrolytes,
keep pumping it with fluids and then the fluids just flushed out of your system
quicker and then you can replenish them quicker.
You know,
I've got to have a dolce on and talked to him about that shit would say whatever
adultery is doing,
probably stick to that everybody.
Yeah.
Tiago Alvarez never looked better in his last fight.
That's another thing.
A lot of guys are coming in to like real light,
like the week of like Mochida well Machita walked around that 203 pounds when we
just champ.
When he's competing at two fives,
203 pounds.
It's tough for him.
That's his natural weight.
Yeah.
What's your sweat?
He does,
you know he's thinking to go into one 70 no.
Yup.
That's what he said in an interview.
The way the week of the fight,
they said he could go to one 70.
I was asking them,
I was in the locker room.
The training room.
Yeah.
I see.
That's the thing,
and people ask me about cutting a two o two oh five all time.
When you go down a weight class,
everyone's skills get better.
Everyone's way faster.
So sometimes it like,
so my advantage at heavyweight is cardio speed,
right?
We are going to in two or five now you're now you're,
it's almost even,
it doesn't become your advantage really.
I don't think there's comes a point of diminishing returns,
right.
Hits the,
there was,
you
know,
v
Talk.
It looks like he's wearing them.
I honor him,
but he's just got that natural sort of dark,
just a black eye all the time.
The pure smoldering just smoldering is right.
Concentrate smoldering little cutie on UFC.
Now here it is.
Here's your show again.
Look at me picking up weights and I'm doing it on some fake grass.
Fake.
Everybody has to have fake grass.
He builds champions from the inside out.
Dun,
Dun Dun.
It looked like that was Rashad Evans,
these guys to running your strength coach was having me,
Loren Landow invited me to run,
come run with the NFL.
Some of the NFL.
No I did not.
It was I had to get on a plane to go to Mexico.
I don't want to get to humiliate it.
Do you want to get humiliated?
By the way,
would it come up in this?
She was to any way because guess what?
I don't want to have to try to run against the Denver Broncos.
You're not running against them.
You're jumping in working.
Yes I am.
I'm in my mind.
The mind of Brian Cowen.
Yeah,
he's running.
Definitely don't show up or you not going to be all you want,
but their dicks and a slap in the face as they run by it.
Yeah.
Dot.
Definitely don't show up then.
I thought you,
I thought you're going as like a fan boy.
It'd be cool for,
even if I was,
does it make me feel good about myself?
How many,
many times a week.
Are you working out Brian?
You talk a lot about working at twice a day.
Uh,
I don't know if you know,
not quite honestly.
I just something almost every day.
Really?
Yeah.
Say Really?
You made up a nose job?
I didn't make
a weird thing to make up one.
It why?
Nobody definitely made up the part about them taking cartilage out of your nose.
Here's what they did.
What Dr Dr Doctor Cartilage and they put it under it right here.
Look,
here's the problem.
I think if you're a doctor,
please write in about how they take a plastic splint and they do put it right
there.
We were talking about sort of keep that thing up.
They did to me too.
They'd make,
but it's plastic.
It's not hard.
This is exactly what he said.
He said when you were under,
you're under for a long time.
Your nose,
tons days,
a hundred days in a techs and stuff and I had to take,
I had to add a piece of cartilage right under here that's so calling his dick
knows they have to probably found inside of the spare car.
Brian,
there's no spirit.
I don't know.
I'm not a doctor guys on that,
you know,
long time ago build you out and we're back on it.
I tried bailing young guys 16 years ago.
Things get real shaky and he's talking about something.
I have to stick to my guns here.
I had cartilage in the nose.
Um,
I think I don't really have a ton times defense.
He is at the box to him all the time.
He's there a lot.
I'll give them,
I believe that.
I believe that blocks and a lot.
I like working out.
It's good for you and need it.
I feel better if I'm not,
I don't want to work at I.
I get a little crazy.
Yeah.
I like your boy.
Lauren took me through a workout for an hour and a in that Denver altitude and I
didn't get a lot of weights.
Let me tell you something.
I have trouble.
I'm having trouble walking around right now.
Oh,
this is supposed to be a good site.
This happened earlier.
A drowned on Martine's humbly kicks in the nuts.
The Rosie Martinez is the guy that Donald Cerrone k code.
He said,
yeah,
champion.
Yeah,
he's with a bad head kick.
Mcnasty head kick.
Yeah.
It was a Shin Shin to the neck.
It's just walking in Bang,
Bang.
Just head movement.
Not a lot of technique,
just straight forward muscular guys are just walking down.
The dude has good striking and could use Jitsu too.
He's really good to just to mark.
Definitely better.
Definitely best or better than the guy with the beard of the guy.
Who were you talking about?
The Guy Without the beard?
Martine's he's the guy that Serone KOD and his last fight,
but he saw is when we ties.
Very good too,
man.
There's so many good fighters now.
It's just such a crazy time for the sport.
Crazy.
It's amazing.
You mean you've seen these guys on an other organizations,
you've seen these guys and other shows you're seeing every week.
Like every time it was a new car,
there's some new guy who's coming up.
You know what was weird is that at the UFC expo,
obviously it's the UFT expo.
So everyone's,
they're looking for UFC fighters.
I can't walk through.
Right.
It's a beast.
You have to have security.
Most UFC fighters do.
If you're a popular fighter,
you can't walk through,
uh,
Chandler from Bella.
I saw him like he'll shit this channeling I've,
I've ever seen.
We're only understanding my belt.
Not One person stopped him walk.
I could walk straight through.
That's the difference.
Bell Tours.
Oh,
you want to go to Bella toward God.
Good luck.
No sponsors.
No one knows who you are.
People might kind of watch but not really unless you're rampage Jackson for now.
Do you think that it's bell tours sticks around changes?
It's Goofy fucking name.
I think.
Look there on Spike TV.
Oh Nice.
Elder Andrea and I think what's the biggest move they've ever made?
Hiram.
Scott Coker.
Oh yeah,
that is nice.
I like got to get some young talent though,
man.
You can't be,
I mean I love rampage but you need,
you need to build your own.
You can't have x UFC guys.
Right.
But that was how they built that paper view.
They sold 100,000 paper views.
The reason why they did is because the Tito Ortiz and cause a rampage.
I agree.
Yeah,
that's,
Oh,
beautiful.
Straight left.
Oh and a kick to the sac or Rooney.
Ouch.
That's down tick shot down shot tech shop that I talked to two group is about
and Duke and del Grantee says the same thing.
He said you got to wear a tie cop,
they'll steal Teichopsia they stay fully [inaudible] they go through it.
I got a diamond cutter love rate,
right?
Yeah.
Protects this bill protects it really protects you.
Protects his nine piece of a Dick.
I got dime piece only the best for this thing.
But this is what I was going to tell you what telegraph they said and what uh,
Duke Roufus said,
it's like the Thai cups are steel and so when someone kicks you,
it hurts foot.
That make sense?
Yeah.
And it just like completely snugs up against your junk.
Just can't go [inaudible] like snuffaluffagus in a ski mask.
I mean you're tying it in place.
You said it feels uncomfortable and it wedges.
Shapes.
Yeah,
you tie it through like a wedge like goes up your ass like a g string.
But after the fight is over,
first of all,
the area near your butthole must smell just rain.
Maybe you can wear it to the mall.
They to watch him get ready to watch it.
I'm telling you guys,
you want to see this.
You know what?
I see this definitely.
He goes,
you kicked me in the nuts.
You kicked me in the nuts.
All right.
Oh No,
man,
you Levine was on that one.
All right.
Very nice guys get upset when he kicked him in the nuts.
Pretty decent back.
It's good.
Call that Brandon.
Good back structure.
They're called it.
What happened earlier today,
Brian?
Oh yeah,
I know.
I was just saying.
Yeah.
Do you remember the part where I said,
I heard this was a good fight and I said yes.
So we just kicked in the nuts.
Not a close listener guys.
Not when.
It's not about you,
about details.
If we're talking about you,
you'd be both.
Yeah,
I get very,
I get,
I can write here so,
and we know Heinz world.
He had a nose job in the rocks,
25 years old.
I wasn't a nose job.
It was a deviated septum.
There is a difference,
man.
I can't tell you when I told people I was,
we were going to do this,
but we'll get that beautiful right hook.
Oh my goodness.
Go easy on me.
Oh yeah.
That's all they said.
Do you understand Brian counts like my brother.
You fucking idiots.
And people listening because he brings lunch.
Rock was 24 years old by the way.
He deserves it.
He deserves everything.
He didn't have cartilage putting his fucking nose.
We all know that.
He may let it stay up.
I'll call the doctor right now.
You guys probably really isn't a black belt in taekwondo,
but it's okay.
That's what this shit
is fucking what's his face as a wrestler?
La Tanning chain.
Him.
Channing Tatum Hung Shannon
one.
Oh my goodness.
This is that movie about that fucking crazy ass hole.
This is that movie about Sholtz.
Yes.
Oh boy.
Dave Schultz and Mark Schultz about that.
The guy who was a patron.
Yeah.
What the fuck was his name
was?
He was at Mac.
He was a big mogul,
uh,
or came from a family.
Um,
damn it.
Oh man,
that was his name.
I can't remember.
Let's see.
I'll pull it up right here.
It was killed by dupont.
John Haunt John Dupont.
Really Rich Guy,
like to wrestle with people and Steve Carell's playing dupont.
Wow.
That'd be a good man.
Apparently he knocks him out of a fucking park.
Really?
Yeah.
By the way,
Chan rounds the Channing Tatum dime piece.
You need to make your body look way better.
If you went on to play Mark Schultz,
bitch,
how about he's a little chunky and a 22 jump street and Chubby Joe.
What's name Jonah Hill?
Jonah Hill's valid.
Great.
Compared to join it.
What?
He's like,
yeah,
I kind of have it,
but if you notice in 22 jump street and this kind of stuff I know is cause I'm
super vain.
He had his shirt on the entire time.
The other one that you'd take your shirt off and from what I saw in that
preview,
he looked all right.
Well,
yes.
I mean in my opinion that's like offensive to me because if you've ever seen
what Mark Schultz looks like,
Mark Schultz,
the wrestler is a fucking animal beast.
It'd be like the rock plain Hercules and it's like a smooth build.
That full is jack to play Herculean.
She got,
he's jacked.
Well Schultz,
when he was in his prime to grab guys,
he used to get guys in in illegal moves.
Like he'd,
he'd use cameras and he would hit a Komora and just rip guy shoulders off while
I was taking them down.
Mangled guys.
Yeah.
I mean he was a fucking,
and I don't know the story of that movie,
but I'll for sure buy a ticket to that.
It's a fascinating story because these guys were all broke and dupont would pay
these guys to come to his compound,
built this wrestling thing and wrestle with them and like roll around with them
and get all sweaty and gay with them.
And then you get game.
Oh,
is gay.
Was He being funny or no?
No,
I'm not being funny at all.
It's totally true.
And He,
a wound up killing.
Um,
he wound up killing Dave Schultz who was a great wrestler.
I want to see a movie.
I mean,
me just told me the whole plot
based on some shit.
Yeah,
man.
There's more to the movies,
good movies,
different and the movie,
he becomes a Werewolf.
I'll tell you what I saw that new horror movie with a Dui.
Is anyone likes scary movies here?
No.
Scary.
Eric Bana.
You know what I'm talking about?
What's it called?
It just came out last week.
You know what I'm talking about and know what is it?
The d?
Yeah.
He's a cop and it supposed to be a true story.
Oh yeah.
What's the scariest Shit move for you?
Scariest movie of all time.
The cadre,
the cadre,
you
God,
Goddamn.
Yeah.
I'm
going to say the,
you're all of 60 years.
Whatever conjuring.
Actually cadre was scary.
I,
I'll,
I'll give you that.
It was scary.
No,
this new movie with,
there's bad,
what's it called?
What does it deliver us from evil,
evil with Eric Bana.
I'll tell you what.
Definitely slept with my lights on.
Yeah.
I'm not afraid.
A minute.
I had my lights on.
Did you?
It was scary,
man.
Joe,
what's your scared?
I live by myself,
man.
Scariest movie of all time.
I'll say that.
I don't know.
I mean not the home and the almond was scary.
I would have to think about that.
I the angel heart scare the shit out of me,
man.
You guys think the only thing new Brian?
No,
I don't.
Yeah.
Anything Angel are scared the shit out of me for real.
The extremism is a cop out,
man.
It's X.
Maybe greatest of all time though.
Know what the grace of all time as far as a scary movie horror movie.
Yeah.
Oh No,
no.
Because you've got to put them in perspective.
Like it might've been great down then you watch it now.
You're bored is fun watching it now you're bored.
Watching recently,
about four years ago and I was pretty damn scared in the middle.
You'd washing it.
You were tweeting and checking your back.
Then I barely see.
That's the thing.
When I,
when I saw it delivers from evil,
when it,
when I saw that movie,
I saw it at the marina theaters where there's that dining experience,
this fuck next to me's chewing on popcorn.
He has like a Margarita.
It fucks up the whole experience.
I will be terrified.
Chompy choppers over here is on Twizzlers and sour patch kids balls deep in his
girl.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like,
dude,
reclining back and shit.
It's not as scary.
The shiny things,
good one that's shining is a,
it was scary as shit.
That might be that my scary that filmed in Colorado might jump.
I might jump ship and say I might,
I might.
I don't have any characters too.
I don't usually stick to my original,
but I,
I'd say the shining is a,
with the conjuring,
the Texas chainsaw massacre was pretty fucking scary too because never really
pictured the original one or the one who Jessica Biel original.
No,
I liked the one.
Just go Beal.
Yeah.
Well I loved it because of Jessica Biel.
Me Too.
I'll take it because of that.
That was a scary goddamn movie.
You know what else was scary,
man,
jaws.
Jaws was fun.
I then ruined me for the ocean to song.
Got attacked by a great white off the Manhattan beach.
But I think,
I think the guy,
they were long distance swimmers right?
And they,
they had hooked the great white as a seven footer.
Hey,
guess what?
I don't give a fuck what happened.
He got attacked by a great white,
but they did say he was fishing and,
and the guy caught a great white.
Yeah,
he was.
He's going to do with it.
What are you gonna do with it?
He was really going to,
in 40 minutes later,
the slums and swimmers swim between the Rod and basically the shark and the
shark bit.
The dude in the torso.
He's fine though.
Gangster Tattoo.
That's right.
Super Cool.
Tattoos.
I just want to get bit,
just got until the story.
Yeah.
Jarls was scary though.
I'll give you,
that was a scary one.
Yeah,
that was very,
so I'm guessing.
No one seeing the country.
I have,
I saw it.
Here's another one that was curious character 28 days later.
That was scary.
See,
that's rom to save removing that does nothing for me.
You know what scared me was,
uh,
what was that movie?
Paranormal activity.
The first one.
The first one is real.
I saw the Blair witch project.
You see that?
Yeah.
I thought it was real.
I was super skinny.
He thought it was real.
It was a home camera man.
The way they filmed it,
it was pretty genius in that sense.
But I didn't,
I didn't really,
but a Blair witch project scared me a little bit.
And so did the second one,
Blair,
which scared me.
I saw Blair witch with my buddy Chris Mcguire.
We went to a,
we were working in Houston.
It was doing the laugh,
laugh,
stop,
which doesn't exist anymore.
And these kids that worked at the movie theater across the street came to the
show and they said,
hey,
do you guys want to go see the Blair witch project?
Just all of us in the movie theater.
We have the keys.
And we were like,
are you fucking kidding me?
And so we did a show,
I think it was like a Thursday night show.
So we did like eight o'clock show after show,
you know,
say goodbye to everybody,
go across the street.
And we,
uh,
they turned on the movie theater.
They turned on the lights,
lock the door.
We went in,
they turned on the fucking the theater and we sat down and watched Blair witch
and it scared the piss out are super skid us.
Well first I was like,
this is fucking a tie was him.
It was so low budget,
so low budget and then I saw it again in a movie with a bunch of people and it
was whack when they felt,
when they found it was titan.
Yeah,
you need to be alone.
That's a really,
that's scary setting.
Some guy brought his three years old during the whole movie.
If you're alone in a big movie theater,
you could die right there.
That can be a trap he's setting.
It's true.
It's an na.
They were,
you know,
one kid thing like that.
It was ring and he weighed 80 pounds.
It was a girl that was overweight like no one was getting her if anybody's
getting hurt.
It was funny though,
but they were nice.
It was cool that they did that for us.
That was really fun.
Oh by the way,
I'm,
I will be there.
You're going to plug your fucking dates.
July 19th.
I'll be at the West Palm Beach,
so Prov sub bitch.
So make sure you come by.
I will be bringing heat.
So we officially hunting the last week in September.
We do you down for Alaska last week.
I thought you said first week.
Now you're changing it like an idiot.
You're changing the dates.
I know you.
No you didn't.
You didn't give me an injection.
I have the text here.
Don't make me pull it up.
Please pull it up because that was the last week.
No,
hold please.
Please hold.
What do you guys go on a hunt again?
Blacktail this time's going to be blacktail deer in,
um,
in,
uh,
Alaska.
It's Steve Grinnell was place.
I'm here.
Brian talking.
Are you around the end of September?
Shit,
I told Joe the answer is yes.
You are.
You around.
So you are around the,
okay.
So,
uh,
it'll be like,
I think,
think the,
uh,
the dates he gave me are like,
I think it's like,
uh,
the 29th from the 29th on and talk to Ober.
[inaudible].
What do you,
what do you guys,
uh,
killing the blacktail deer with?
Bazookas or some no rifles,
bro.
Bro.
And maybe even a bone arrow.
Animal Lover.
I'm bringing my ball.
Yeah.
Well guess who's going to shoot it?
Oh,
that's not,
I
can't pull it back to Jim's son.
I don't want to talk about it.
I am in the gym all the time with Martin Landau.
I'm saying,
I'm saying get,
get on a bench press.
Hey Bro.
How many pull ups that I do?
Yeah,
but you weigh eight pounds.
How many pull ups?
You keep saying that,
but what you do are kicking your leg.
You don't weigh a lot.
So make that motion,
Bro.
That's all he kept doing.
See you talk about how many pull ups you do,
but what do you weigh?
I weigh 170 pounds or you (716) 516-0301 70 and how many chin ups can you do?
31 he did 31 I'll get 31 yeah.
It was like use like throwing is,
what do you call it kip in pro give that money goes.
It's like crossfit.
I did at crossfit.
I said one friend,
you're suspended from being my friend for two days cause he said crossfit.
Yeah.
Well Brian You keep those aren't chin ups.
Those are kipping Chin ups and those guys who do those,
they do like a hundred well I did,
I know like fade or when he was a heavyweight you still like a hundred really?
Oh God.
There's a video of fate or doing kipping Chin ups.
It's a frightening always in like the wilderness of Russian.
He's like Kevin Woods
Champs and he's in a single like some white Whitey tighties just fucking doing
work.
Well he used to wear like black socks and fucking running shoes from like from
the 80s some new balances with black socks and his Whitey tighties.
But no one said shit cause he's such a bathroom.
I was like,
thank him.
The Gym and guys are in black socks and white.
He tied,
he's trying to do the same shit.
It's not like they have foot locker,
the middle of Russia
where you get your sneakers yourself,
you steal them from people who are running by you
tack on it then yeah,
he uses it like a lot of old school training methods.
Like you put like caught up hand weights and throw punches kind of caught up.
Well you know where it caught up with him.
I was,
it's interesting because I was watching some old fade or fights.
Huge fade or fan and who's not.
If you're not,
you're not an MMA fan.
Him and Sakuraba.
Yeah.
Well was just a different thing than,
he was a totally different thing.
But I used to go back and watch his fight.
I was watching his fights recently and he was much bigger back in the day.
Physically bigger,
stronger about two 30 you mean bigger than watch other guys you mean or what do
you,
more muscle than he did at the end of his career and his crew.
Stop lifting weights done with the weights.
It was just doing fight training.
But if you go back to like the Fujita fight being be thick traps,
big shoulders was fucking strongly shit and somewhere along the line they just
get tired of lifting weights.
I think.
I mean I don't,
I don't know what it was.
What led him to the side or older.
Right and started losing muscle mass maybe?
No,
no.
He stopped lifting weights like he talked about it.
He just did fight training only later on in his career.
I think he thought the technique was more important than physical strength,
which is true for the most part.
I've gone towards that route toward personally.
Yeah.
Let's see.
I'm going to go in the gym and spend an hour lifting weights,
don't out weights or I can be on the mat,
work on my boxing technique or Jujitsu and wrestling.
I'm going to go do Jujitsu to know what Steve Maxwell's thought on that is.
It was a really interesting cause.
Maxwell spent a lifetime with strength and conditioning working with athletes.
He thinks that if you're going to lift weights for sports,
you shouldn't lift weights like strength and conditioning style.
He thinks if you're doing like Mike Martial arts,
if you're in the middle of like training technique,
he goes,
you should do like sets,
like do sets of dead lifts,
do sets of bench two sets.
She likes to incorporate lights at the rounds now just to get stronger.
I was like,
you shouldn't work on your endurance.
Like you shouldn't be like doing these fucking crazy strength and conditioning
workouts while you're in camp working out for fights.
He's like,
if you're,
he goes,
you should lift weights to keep your muscle mass and to keep your strength,
but all your conditioning should come from your kickboxing,
should come from your wrestling.
That should come from Egypt.
Actually,
I'm actually going to Arizona on Thursday and meet with this new,
uh,
this new strength conditioning coach who Tim Teebo works with.
And uh,
yeah,
I'm going out there with Tim and he said the exact same thing and this guy works
with everyone.
He said that he's like,
you shouldn't have a session where you're working,
you know,
reps and stuff like that.
He's said exactly what you just told me.
These guys are saying that your skills are the most important thing and your
strength and you all your your physical strength like the mass it's size that
you could put on and maintain.
He's like you should maintain that,
you should get strong,
you should do all that but don't do like strength and conditioning like while
you were in a fight,
like the crossfit stuff afterwards.
Don't do that because you're not going to have the same energy to do your
Jujitsu work.
Like when I was doing Jujitsu all the time,
if I would lift weights I could lift weights in the morning.
And did you do to at night?
You know why?
Because I would do like a set of bench and then I would sit around me and I,
Bravo would talk shit for fire,
laugh and goof off and then we'd do another set so we would get all the strength
workout in but I still had energy to train at night.
Whereas like if I do my kettle bell routine than I do if I do that shit,
that's a wrap.
You're done.
I'm done.
That's interesting man.
That when you do strength training,
do you do it twice a week when you're in camp and camp?
I do it.
I do it twice a week.
Yeah.
But how to camp,
like now I lift four or five times.
I kept trying to get bigger,
stronger.
So when I go and camp,
my body's going to break down and we lose some size.
I just try to keep it,
you know what I'm saying?
But like people asked me like,
uh,
even younger fighters at rain or Grace Academy,
like,
oh,
like what,
what should I be doing in the weight room?
Stuff like that.
So if you're younger fighter,
you shouldn't really waste your time in the weight room.
You don't get paid to bench and squat and power clean.
Right.
Paid to submit bitches and knock them out.
So work on summit and knocking bitches out.
Here's the finals.
This is the light heavyweight finals,
right?
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Those are those breasts or yeah,
those are,
um,
Gyno,
mastercard got him Asca and Corey Anderson,
Matt Van Buren set of Nipples on him.
Then that dude,
the other dude,
the other dude does not him.
That dude straight.
Yeah,
him.
I kind of yarn as a fucking animal.
So it was Corey.
This is a good fight.
Really good fight.
And this is like when we're talking about like this,
the high level of guys that are coming up,
man,
these guys that are fighting,
I mean we,
you go back to the day will like when Forrest was fight and Stephan Bonner and
then look at these guys and you're,
you know,
you're dealing with some pretty high level guys now.
There,
there are lots of well rounded,
a lot more well rounded.
Well first of all,
dude,
six,
five,
two a five.
That's insane.
No,
he's next door.
Big Boy.
Oh,
trouble.
Cory's cracking him.
Oh,
he's rocked man.
He's out of it.
Oh yeah.
He's to cover it up.
I was super out of it.
He's taken it.
They show they should.
Oh No,
look,
he's coming back.
No,
he's not.
he's not out of,
might be done.
He's super out of it.
He didn't.
Wow.
I'm always coming back.
Oh.
But he's still trading.
Oh my goodness.
In the ISO.
It's over.
It's super over.
Pours all over him.
No.
Why take him?
See,
I just smash them.
Look at this.
Nah,
he should have kept it on the feet.
I Dunno.
You can recover right now.
You can recover this.
Not like this.
A lot more than when you're on the feet.
Mario's going to stop it.
That's it.
That's how you get Corey.
Corey,
two tough ones have just been some whoopings son.
Corey Anderson can crack power the nipple sun.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
People don't know.
There's a bunch of different ways to get those nipples.
It doesn't mean you did steroids.
No,
not at all really,
but a lot of times.
What are the other ways?
A lot of times it means
not to put you on the spot.
What are the other ways again,
real quick,
how it go.
How do I avoid,
I like Joe Scott really quiet.
I'd like to hear everyone just got quiet about it,
but nobody's pointing fingers.
I didn't see any nails,
bro.
Try to be nice.
We had a gun.
One guy that fought in the UFC wants that was like,
those are close up on the nipples are one guy fought in the UFC wants a that had
like a serious problem like when he was younger I guess he did a lot of steroids
and like he was jumping up and down inside the octagon and he's,
his boobs were like,
oh no hopping.
Oh,
like flopping flopping.
And he was fighting.
He was fighting one 70.
Damn.
Corey can crack.
Look at this beautiful striking straight through the middle.
Boom.
Great straight shot.
Boom,
boom.
But when that fight was about 15 seconds long and his hand wraps came apart,
who fucking wrapped his hands?
Look at that.
It's that war tape.
Yeah,
on the thumb it stuff.
Um,
yeah.
You never want to set it to,
it's like that.
You don't want nipples like that.
Not that bad.
I mean
it doesn't take away from his great performance.
Go to Gold's gym.
He went,
guys don't go to those jams.
Oh my god Bro.
Get a brawl on,
what'd you say that correct me if I'm wrong in that place.
Last time I worked out there smells like
protein farts.
It's exactly what it smells like.
Yeah.
This is niche burnables Mel Gibson,
so work I love it.
Played a bad guy to working around doubles as my boy Wesley Snipes.
These expendables movie America loves him.
There's a little talk about you fighting now unless they a long time ago,
it was a long time ago.
What happened on that?
He decided not to get his ass kicked.
It was that,
what's the story is actually going to go down.
Yeah.
We had lawyers involved and everything.
What happened?
Contract.
He changed his mind.
He called you out.
How did you stars Campbell Mclaren,
who was the guy who was the original producer for the ultimate fighter?
Calls me up out of nowhere and says,
this is gonna sound crazy,
but would you be interested in fighting Wesley's times?
I want it.
What are you talking about?
And so then they start explaining what's going on and I was training,
how long ago was this?
2006 so blade was,
he did make blade.
He,
that would scare me out of the fight,
I think.
What was going on?
I think what was going on was that he,
the IRS was coming down on them hard and he's looking for cash.
Yeah,
he was looking at trialing unathletic by the,
no,
he knows martial arts but never competed and no Jujitsu.
And I think he just thought it was just a wrapper and then somewhere along the
line,
I don't know what happened,
but he just decided not to do it.
You know,
I think if you've never competed your whole life and you have these ideas,
plus I think he's probably hanging around with a bunch of dudes who are taking
Bolivian marching powder and like,
you know what,
he's going to have fucking time to make your money money.
There's a lot of motherfuckers out there doing that karate,
doing all kinds of martial arts,
but they don't know what,
you know,
you got something special inside you broke,
this is your time to shine.
Heart of a lion and trunk from blade and doing all these stunts was like,
fuck yeah,
I'll do it.
Well if you talked to pat and Oswald Patton Oswald did blade with him and
apparently there was just bags of cocaine involved making of that.
Yeah.
Panopto has a hole a bit.
He does about it.
Wow.
About being on the set with,
with,
with Wesley.
Like how fucked up.
He was like he went through some dark periods,
three lines in them.
[inaudible] just killed vampires don't stop.
No,
they parade moving.
They pulled the lines from him,
hired a double to do all the scenes.
There was another guy,
so he did nothing movie.
So he did nothing.
I don't know what happened,
but half that movie like Patton Oswald has a whole bit about how they brought in
the way cooler black guy to pretend to be played.
But that guy didn't get a talk.
They headed west.
I had some struggles with,
uh,
he had some issue.
Well also I had some issues at a bunch of questionable characters that told them
not to pay taxes.
Let me,
let me get this straight,
Joe.
So you weren't scared at all about a coked up Wesley snipes that just got done
doing blade?
No,
not at all.
Coming at you like a spider.
Nothing.
No clinch to ground ground,
squeeze,
dap or sleep.
But when he's,
when he's all coked up,
just like fidgeting,
like freaking out,
worried about the
gas out pretty fast.
Um,
I a guy who has never done Jujitsu,
who gets 170 pounds.
If he's not,
he's not,
he's not.
Trust me.
You always do this.
You always do it.
She's not big at all.
He's not thinking I've seen him in person.
Really?
Yeah,
please.
He's heavier than I know.
I don't think there'll be,
I get this,
the gable grip around the west and then that's
when you're like this and then on top of you and then what you're going to do,
you're going to make mistake,
mistake Japanese or sound like an old Japanese
Brazilian to jasmine.
I when he's on that devil's Dandruff and he's all coked up.
You can't get ahold of him even better.
I was planning on failing every drug test partner.
I mean if they tested me for being like wandering and chill.
You guys have been great.
I do all my training high,
so I was trying to figure out whether I was going to fight.
You always train high Jujitsu?
Yeah.
Why?
I don't always know why I like it.
I like doing Jujitsu high,
like to smoke they here for and what I really like.
I like eating it,
eating it and enrolling.
I think it makes me more sensitive.
It makes me more aware of what's going on.
Makes some more focused.
I completely zone in.
A lot of guys do Jujitsu.
I'm a lot of guys.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm aware.
It's just what your,
I've never right.
Remember Bro,
I'm telling you if you did it,
you might not.
Never.
If you have some time off and you're do Jujitsu,
you do.
And so you know you're not going to get tested.
You're not really going to smoke pot and it was all just joking around.
Right.
Kind of joking around on the five cats.
Try once.
I'm telling you you'd love it.
I mean,
I don't know if you'd love it,
but I would assume you'd love it.
Yeah.
Eddie Bravo.
Those that every goddamn time.
Bj Penn and it was a little high and last night
I was talking about the Shitty dad stories,
which I had nothing to contribute to homeboys.
One story.
It was awful.
He had a great damn long hair.
He kept trying to bring a story into it.
Oh,
that dude.
Yeah,
it's horrible story.
I kept looking at it.
I kept looking for it.
It's like how often you talk to your dad and he goes every day.
But then I was like,
Oh,
well your dad's very much in your life.
He goes,
no,
but my dad's all success when he calls me.
He tries to give me tips and shit as a nice guy.
So let's not talk too much about giving names.
It was,
there was a little horrible story.
It was.
It was,
yeah.
There's sometimes dudes get around,
guys like you guys to tell great stories and they try to throw their own story
in it and they don't realize their stories.
You know,
you're dealing with Eddie Bravo,
who's a great dose story telling my Buddy Justin,
who's a great stuff.
Justin's story.
It was depressing as fuck my buddy Justin.
It got dark,
dark,
dark.
You know,
my,
my story is not as bad as his story is pretty dark.
It's bad.
It's bad that,
that not,
you know me I liked,
I liked,
I'll talk your frickin air off.
I didn't say a word last night.
I can't contribute.
Yeah.
Can't contribute to the story.
So I'm not doing,
nothing's worse when then someone doesn't know what they're talking about and
they are,
especially with experiences like that,
my parents,
my dad loved the shit out of me straight up.
So when you guys talk about these shitty childhoods,
I can't really jump in.
Right.
There's nothing worse when we got it.
Oh,
I hear that Bro.
I hear that.
One time I went to Mcdonald's.
He,
my dad buy me a fucking
happy meal.
I feel you bro.
I always presents at Christmas.
I was like,
no.
There was no,
I was like,
this is too much.
Yeah.
Depressing childhood stories are rough.
They're hard to deal with.
But yeah,
the one dude's story,
it was not so good.
They compare it to me.
Justice was horrible.
Mine wasn't the best,
and he's just horrible.
Trying not to laugh.
I can't hide when I'm,
when I think something's funny.
I was trying to not laugh at his story and he kept bringing it back in,
even as frank,
hey bro,
uh,
maybe,
maybe pipe down.
He goes,
no,
no man.
Fuck that.
It sucks when Your Dad's disappointed in you.
Sober up spilled spilled half a drink on my change.
As the day went on,
he got even more drunk.
Really trying to explain something to me later on that night.
And it was tough.
It was like,
he was like waking up from anesthesia
something to me.
I was like,
it's okay man.
I got it.
I get it.
I get it again.
Happens in Vegas about about three 30 in the morning.
You'll get cornered by small.
I don't hang out with anyone that I can't get down with it.
Uh,
so did,
did you know him from before and now he's my buddy Justin,
his pal.
He's a good dude.
He's just got hammered and you know what happens,
man?
Like I said,
when people are around,
guys like you guys had tell great stories and they want to contribute and tell a
great story too,
and they're just not used to don't do that.
You know,
you're around a fucking worldclass standup comedian like Brian Cowen.
It tells great fucking stories and you want to throw yours into the mix.
Good luck.
He came though,
Bro.
He doesn't have any,
he had this false sense of reality because he's drunk.
Nothing like being around Joey Diaz when he starts talking.
I've never met him,
man.
I hear him on your podcast.
He's dope.
He's 20 scratch ever lived.
I've been a lot of funny.
Why can't you bring him or one the fight anytime.
I'll do it next time.
Next one we do.
He'll do it if he's in town.
He wants to do the fighter and the kid.
I talked to him two days ago.
He's the funniest guy that's ever lived.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
I've met a lot of funny guys.
Sopranos,
is that,
no,
no.
He looks like the guy from big pussy.
Yes.
He's not at all.
Not really.
If you saw big pussy,
I saw him.
He looks working on as an actor though,
man.
He's worked a lot.
But you know what,
he's making more money now with his standup than ever and it's all because of
the Internet.
So because of podcast,
cause he can be himself.
He just never runs out of stories and he's got a fucking personality that goes
on for days.
This is Bj Penn and Frankie Edgar and I'm going to Piss.
So please uh,
be kind when I leave the room we're going to,
we're about to see two fucking legends go down real quick.
Uh,
I was getting there.
I look at the apartment.
Please look at him.
Come on.
I couldn't look more normal car look more like the nine to five.
He looks like a nine to fiver.
How he does it certainly does.
And I love,
you know how much I love him,
how much I pick them every time I've just,
I just find it amazing.
He's having a knee surgery and then waiting for his title.
Shot,
smart move.
I think
this was a,
this was a mistake right?
In his hands weren't up right.
Is that what,
what,
what was going on with that?
Hold,
hold,
hold.
Blight.
I don't give a fuck.
We just already saw that man.
Oh,
what happened?
He got punched in the face very,
very hard.
He got disoriented and then more punches happen.
Well,
okay.
Thanks a lot doctor.
No help.
I mean,
what do you want me to tell you may have punched directly in the face.
Yeah,
but his hands should have been out.
Right?
It's tough,
man.
Shit happens.
I love Brian Stann cause everyone does nothing.
Not to love about the gay.
Okay.
Square jawed marine could,
he'd look anymore American.
He should be,
you should took to be a US citizen.
You should have to know who Brian is.
He's saying he can run for president.
Yeah.
Fucking wind by,
I would vote for him.
I think Chael Sonnen could too.
If both.
No,
no,
no.
Before all on more lion.
Before we went in a time machine to six months ago.
I'm chill.
A felon,
let's say before he's a felon.
I love it.
I love chair.
I'd vote for him too.
I want to talk his way into it.
Loving Chels better talk to them Brian.
Oh,
I he finds more clear because he was in fricking doing tours and kill them
bitches.
So it's a lot more clear.
You get real clear.
We started killing bitches.
There's no stuttering when you're ordering Stan.
Stan is very direct,
I guess that going over the final,
they're going to show Eddie Gordon and Diego Lima again.
Why are they showing that?
We did and they just showed us the,
they're killing a little.
I just solid why you be showing this?
Because the last fight was a one round knockout too.
You know there's a lot of knockouts on this guy,
right?
Boom.
Gordon cracks
and tell you what man,
Diego Lima is tough as shit.
You know the the kind of punishment to watch your head containing going to be
fun,
angry.
This is where it should have stopped right there.
I think Gordon looks so angry.
This is like a,
if you wanted to like talk about how evil cage fighting is.
Look at this.
Wow.
Was the end of the world in the future when they started looking at that scared
me.
I was like,
yeah,
when they will start looking back in the future about when society crumbled and
when this is like the first steps they were talking about rolling return to the
clad or yeah,
the coliseum.
I mean tell me this isn't the similar to the calcium.
Tell me that reality shows on similar to what you had a good answer when
somebody said,
why is it so popular?
Why is I'm amazed as popular.
And you said it's the closest you can come to watching two men kill each other
with their bare hands.
Yeah.
Cause guess what?
If leave eve Levine or her deans on in there and no one stops it,
someone's dying.
You got the guys out cold and you're stomping his head towards Jello.
Yes.
Yeah.
Unfortunately only reason why the ref is there is to make sure that doesn't
happen.
Yeah.
Damn.
Lot of empty seats back there.
Huh?
Super Empty.
Well was fort just what gets the Sunday in Vegas after 4th of July?
I don't even,
I'm not even a party or I'm fucking exhausted.
I was thinking that this morning cause I left this morning and when I flew out,
man it was,
the airport was mobbed.
Vegas looked like it was full of zombies.
The airport looked like Zombie.
You gotta you gotta you got about an hour of sleep to kid takes vitamins.
She seen my piss.
It's bright orange.
Really?
You're glowing vita.
Who doesn't do well if I don't get hours of sleep.
Yeah.
Well you trained hard man.
Don't do well.
This is a good weekend man.
I got to real solid workouts and it worked out with della Grog Day and yesterday
I lifted it,
worked out with the um,
uh,
the same time as Rhonda is girl Marina Marina Shit.
Very cool.
Very cool chick works out hall.
She's a beast man.
She's a little beat Rhonda,
his best friend and protege,
she's a bi.
You could tell she's a one 45 or though,
yeah,
she was putting in her strength and conditioning workouts.
She had like a fucking,
like a phone in front of her with all of our routines and stuff.
She put in some fucking work.
I was impressed.
So here it gives,
we're going to watch Frankie Edgar and time I believe,
kit now against Bj Penn.
Bj Penn,
Frankie Edgar's wife,
Frankie Edgar,
Mom Frankie had Chris' Dad.
I love Frankie Edgar.
I love Frankie.
Went down to Jose Aldo is camp,
I guess,
right?
Well,
he did a little bit of training at Nova Uniao but he did most of the training in
Hawaii for this always.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
Ian Mccall,
who,
uh,
was,
he went with Bj down to down to,
uh,
Hilo to train with them.
Does it train?
He said Bj's in incredible shape.
He said Ian has fantastic endurance.
And he said Bj was,
uh,
was out working at me.
He said he was blown away by how good a shape Bj's in.
Now,
I've heard this a million fucking times.
We find out here this literally every fight,
every time.
But what blew me away about this is that first of all,
they're going to fight at one 45.
That's going to be a disaster.
Bj Soria Zombie was making one 55 but whatever he did,
I don't know what he adjusted.
I would love to talk to him about how he changed his body.
But he got down where he was walking around like under one 60 I got a regular
basis and then the fight week he was one 49 fight week without any cutting.
Yeah.
And then he easily made one 45 Frankie weighed one 45.5 BJ weighed one 45 on the
nugget.
Look good at the weigh ins and chase.
You know what I mean?
It look skinny,
but he had trouble making 55 beats and then I didn't know that.
Oh yeah.
He's not taught well.
That's why I fought one 70 all the time.
He fought Nick Diaz,
any fought.
Rory Macdonald,
two big ones.
Seventies Roy MacDonald fight was hard to watch.
And Boys,
my boy that was on such a reach advantage.
Bj Penn,
as far as,
he's a super star,
he is up as big as they get superstar the most down to earth.
Nicest Guy I've ever met in the UFC.
Hands Down Bj.
He's assaulted the earth and these are real warrior,
but you know what man,
he's a guy that has an incredible amount of pride and you know he,
he,
he's got a lot of ego.
He's got a lot of pride.
He loves he,
you know,
he wants to get in there and be the Bj that he used to be.
Well that's why.
That's why he is who he is.
He don't get to that point where they'll have an ego.
Listen,
everyone who fights in the EOC has an ego.
But if he could use that and motivate himself to get back in and kind of shape
that.
He was back when he fought Diego Sanchez back.
We fought Sean Sherk and he was in insane condition back.
How old is he now?
He's trying to,
35 six how
old do you think he's 42 he's Dwayne.
Brian Thinks Bj Penn's 21 years old.
He's the rock scene.
I don't think he was 36 right?
I would say 30 thirties for sure.
Maybe find a long time.
Yeah,
it's been a while.
The WFC,
by the way,
the UFC website is dog shit.
It's horrible.
They,
you can't go to the fighter until their fight is on.
Like if you try to go to the fighter when,
um,
there are fights not on,
it takes you to the previous fight like you,
like if the like to go to the card and when you go to the card it shows like the
fighters and he tried to,
uh,
read the bio on them and it just like,
it doesn't like even allow you to click on it.
It actually takes you back to,
uh,
the other fight.
It's weird.
Okay.
Let's see if I can search fighters.
Pj Pen.
I'm saying Bj,
Bj age and Google.
I'm saying 34.
I'm gonna say 36.
Okay,
let's try here.
Let's see.
Bj Penn Doo Doo Doo Doo to 35.
Wow.
35.
He low how?
35 so for B,
this is,
you know,
last chance for romance at the lighter weights.
Especially,
you know,
heavier guys can last longer.
You know,
they,
they oftentimes like,
especially heavyweights.
Yeah.
Mature a little bit later and are still effective to,
I take my Flintstone vitamins,
word,
word up,
or listen,
I'm rooting for Bgi.
Wam to win.
I don't think he stands a chance.
Really.
I don't,
it hurts to say,
cause I love Bj.
Know what the odds arm.
No,
I don't.
They they opened up at 10 to one.
Frankie.
Frankie is the makes sense.
It makes sense.
Frankie's is outstanding.
I mean,
he's just a fucking,
he's a stud.
He's a fucking stud.
He's an outstanding athlete.
He's got some of the best footwork in the UFC,
I would say.
Yeah.
I'd say if not the best.
No one's got a bigger heart.
No one's got a better chin.
No one's more of a fucking a Gamer.
And Frankie,
he's his game.
It's fuck.
Take those gray Maynard fights.
Jesus Christ,
Bro.
Hit his coach.
Mark Henry I worked with,
before I fought cro cop,
I flew up to New Jersey with his camp.
I was with recall Amita,
uh,
his striking coach Mark Henry and uh,
it's insane.
I've never seen anything like it.
If you watch Mark Henry in the corner,
he's drenched in sweat by the end of the fight.
It's literally like he has a control stick and he's doing this with Frankie.
He just shouting out Frankie.
They have a whole system and code.
He'll go one three,
four,
five,
one three,
four,
five and it changes every fight so he can't pick up on it.
It's like his coach is Peyton manning and is running the offense and he's so
nervous before the fight because he feels like it's banking on him because he
calls every combination.
You see.
Wow.
Nope.
There's no one else like him in the UFC coaching wise.
Yeah man.
Mark Henry,
interesting beast.
Did you get a lot out of working with him?
A ton.
Real aton
cause you're thinking about moving to New Jersey?
I did really and I thought it held you back.
The checks accents
who's with gold chain?
No.
Jersey shore came out and was like heat.
So that Jersey shortcut when MTV and on it,
I'm good.
I'm all set.
If they all look like sneaky,
I'm,
I'm all set.
That's where I was like,
I came to la,
that's where I was born.
Yeah.
Mark.
And he's a beast,
man.
I was working his basement.
I worked with them so much.
Uh,
the calluses on my feet were ripping off because I'd worked in his basement
nonstop at night.
I only did the guy's work ethic is insane.
I don't think there's another coach in the world who works hard in the Markin.
Wow.
So what,
I mean,
so you really get enough credit.
No kidding.
You don't get enough credit.
I was getting it from you.
Did you think about moving down that you really did?
I did.
I did,
but there wasn't big guys.
There was no big guys around anyone.
That's a,
that's a big thing.
And that's a bummer.
A super bummer.
Do you base where you trained by the size of the guys?
Uh,
I base on it on,
on,
uh,
the coaches first I find the coaches and then I always think that at least if
there's big guys in the area,
I'll,
I'll at least get to him somehow.
And honestly I thought me and for doing would work together more.
And then,
uh,
when I first came out to give it like a trial run,
there was word that means we're doing,
we're gonna fight each other.
And me and him started talking shit to each other on Twitter and got out of
hand.
He texts me or tweeting me,
like,
I'll fight you on the moon.
And I put okay,
or we can just do in Las Vegas.
September 21st,
not the moon.
Save your money.
You know,
like rockets are expensive.
Yeah,
that's what I said.
I said,
rocket fuel,
super expensive.
You can't just do it in Las Vegas,
Bro.
Definitely won that battle.
Awkward.
Yeah,
but so we're going to fight.
But then he was like,
Nah man.
Like we might have fight.
So he doesn't want to work together.
Great guy though.
How about now?
Would you be,
would you fall?
They still might have to fight,
dude.
They're both in the heavyweights in the UFC.
Are you paying attention?
But you hear the train with him?
I would work with them.
Yeah.
Bj is,
it's kind of weird looking at 'em all skinny.
I don't,
I love his wife.
His out to my favorite in the UFC.
How about he?
He gets so emotional sometimes he cries when he walks out.
Huh?
Look at that.
He didn't get me fired up man.
Looking at them just looking at his face gets me fired up.
I love it.
I'm a huge Bj Penn.
Fair to man.
God Damn.
And Frankie Edgar.
They could not live in more contrast in places.
Right.
One of them lives in paradise.
The other one lives in fucking jersey.
Okay.
That's Mark Henry right there.
Yeah.
So I like those,
uh,
those gloves too.
Big thick padded gloves.
But they still have Tony,
I don't know if you'd be able to pick it up on the broadcast,
but you'll literally here march shouting the entire rounds.
Four,
five,
six,
seven,
nine,
nine.
Just those are all combinations and they change it every camp cause they don't
want people picking up on it.
That's just smart.
Frankie is to,
well it shows you how much work they put in there.
Oh,
Mark Henry,
just off me.
Just when we work together.
I'm talking this,
this notebook
right here.
Completely full notes.
Wow.
It was overwhelming.
I was like,
damn,
no,
you need to go study this for about a year.
What does it feel like when you leave that and you train with someone else and
you don't have all that?
You must feel like,
what the fuck?
I'm not maximizing my potential.
Nope.
I got a guy now here in la because we share the same shit.
Really does the same shit,
but he's just boxing.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
We've talked about that.
We need to talk about that when shut this off.
You know,
talking to us on it.
I've got some new information for you.
All right.
We'll talk some more,
but here it is.
It's going down right now,
man.
Oh,
I'm so excited about this fight.
I almost thought about staying in Vegas just for this fight.
Wow.
That place filled up.
That's shows you,
man.
I'll tell you right now.
Fade or it could be fight in in the prime,
could be fighting a prime frickin whoever and I wouldn't have stayed in babies.
I would've said,
well man,
I dunno.
I would have fade or I would have stayed for not me.
Fade work had been fighting cro cop in their prime.
I would have went home to la right and know me.
I would have told my wife,
listen bitch,
Mike told Jay in the background,
I'll see you in a day.
It's not going to watch free to air and Cro cop,
not me.
I would have paid double for my air ticket today to get home.
That's funny.
But are all the fighters that I wish I'd seen live?
He's never one fader who I saw them live when he beat up Mark Coleman in Vegas.
I never saw him.
Real ass whooping.
That was a real ass weapon.
That was hard to watch.
A horrible,
does it sound like they're bunum or no,
no,
no way.
No one's blue and Bj Penn Bro.
Fucking hey man,
this is wild.
Look at him.
He looks thinner,
man.
He looks like he's way thinner and they're finding it.
One 45 you know Bj fought heavyweight.
He fought Leo Machida over tall five it's called the ROC,
correct?
No promotion the Rock,
right and heavyweight.
No,
he fought.
I mean he did fight in Hawaii,
rumble on the rock.
There was on the rock.
That's those promotion.
But that's not when he fought the Yoda.
He fought Liotta in Japan.
He fought,
he fought Gomi in um,
in Hawaii.
Went Gomi was a legend and he beat the piss out of gummy.
It's when [inaudible] was at its best.
I get that Bj Penn.
God Damn,
look at this amazing and I wish,
I wish I get here.
Walk.
That's a living legend right there folks.
Straight up.
He is a living legend.
Oh,
you like Bruce Lee.
Yeah,
we got Bj Penn fight right now.
he's actually competing.
I'm a big fan of Bruce Lee too,
but I think all this Bruce Lee talks getting out of hand.
I agree with my song in the octagon.
It was,
people were saying he's greatest,
this,
the gray.
So He's a very good actor at some really good ideas that marsh did some great
stuff,
did some great stuff with g Condo,
but however,
he never officially competed.
There's nothing on record.
Last I said,
I think I said this on my podcast,
the fight fighting the kid or in yours,
I forget.
People bombard me with tweets,
like,
how dare you.
No Man,
I'm stating the facts.
I'm sure he's great.
He's great.
One of the best ever did I where?
Bruce Lee t shirts all the time.
I love to sleep.
However,
talk about Heman and Bj Penn.
Same Cynthia.
Exactly it.
Keep it.
One's a warrior.
One's an actor.
Yeah,
I'm,
and again,
he was hugely important.
Bruce Lee's hugely important.
I'm a huge Bruce Lee fan.
He was the original mixed martial artists.
He was the first guy and when I came along in the 1980s when I was doing martial
arts,
when I first started,
they still had this issue where people were loyal to their style,
who still got a lot of that man.
And Bruce Lee was the very first guy and it was even before I was started
training.
The very first guy who came along and said,
that's all nonsense,
like you should use what's useful.
And he built his own style that was based on incorporating all these different
martial turn martial arts into a business.
And then the dragon,
he actually does an arm bar too.
Oh yeah,
he does.
Well,
he worked out a lot with gene,
a gene Lebell Gene Lebell labelle's on the podcast told me some great stories.
That's classic.
Yeah,
tiny guy.
Right.
And he was like 530530557 35 they still really don't know how he died,
right.
They say mixed like hamstring with painkillers.
I get a head injury apparently.
Okay.
Like some sort of annual or something guys,
I know that Chinese mouth.
Let's find out.
Yeah,
I know.
I literally,
I Google it because I was getting so much heat about Bruce Lee and [inaudible]
said he was at like some director's house.
He had a headache.
He took aspirin and then we went home.
He took a painkiller and it killed him.
Okay.
Look at Frank.
He always runs in and you'll see Mark Henry running right behind him.
You see him trying to keep up?
There he is.
Look,
you know there's your Nintendo controller here.
He comes in Tyndall 64 in the house.
Damn Frankie Edgar.
Holy Shit.
Here we go.
Real is Frankie Ben Henderson fights.
Those are so close.
I'd Frankie beating Ben in Denver.
Okay.
Yeah.
I thought he won.
Let me too.
I thought it was very close,
but I thought Frankie one
man,
I can't believe this fight's about to go down.
This is so exciting.
I can't believe that.
Fighting it again.
All right.
Death League collapsed in Golden Harvest Studios and Hong Kong while doing
dubbing work for enter the dragon suffering from seizures and headaches.
He was immediately rushed to Hong Kong Baptist hospitals where doctors treated
him with chicken bones and Voodoo.
No.
Well there's your,
a diagnosis of cerebral edema.
Like why Hong Kong Baptist Anura as I listen to that Hong Kong Baptist hospital.
Okay.
Um,
he had a cerebral edema.
They were able to reduce the swelling.
Um,
wow.
So he had bleeding in the brain,
man.
Wow.
That's fucked up.
And then when they reduced the,
so that was in May,
um,
the same symptoms that occurred in his first collapse where a repeated on the
day of his death in 1973,
Lee was in Hong Kong to have dinner with James Bond Start,
George Lazenby,
whom he intended to make a film.
According to Lee's wife,
he met with producer Raymond Chow at 2:00 PM,
discussed the making of the film.
They worked until 4:00 PM,
drove together at home to the home of Lee's,
a colleague,
Blah Bubba,
blah,
blah.
Three went over the script and then Chow left to attend a dinner meeting.
Lead complained of a headache.
Teen gave him a,
an analgesic painkiller which contained aspirin and a monk's muscle relaxing
around seven 30 went to lie down for a nap.
He did not turn out for dinner.
She came to the apartment but could not wake him up at doctor was summoned,
spent 10 minutes attempting to revive him before sending him to an ambulance.
He was dead at the time we reached the hospital.
There's no visible external injury.
However,
according to autopsy reports,
his brain had swollen considerably.
So it was probably from fucking brain injuries from,
from getting a beating like concussion style could Bei man,
hey.
Oh,
okay.
The doctor stated that he had died from an allergic reaction to the muscle relax
and which he described as a common ingredient in painkillers.
When a doctor's announced Lee's death,
officially it was rural death by misadventure misadventure.
So in other words,
misadventures in a recreational use of drugs or something.
Can this term misadventure well,
that's trying to have an adventure.
And that's what the Bj look at bt.
You can see his abs.
Never seen that before.
I'm Bj.
Well,
when he fought on the,
the four.
Yeah.
But he's obviously in good shape,
man.
This is so interesting.
Definitely going for Bj.
Never root against,
I'm Jay.
I'm so fascinated right now.
Me Too.
And I love his shorts.
Yeah.
Love them
to a prodigy.
I think it was one of the fast ever gives blackbelt correct.
Four years,
three years.
Three years.
Not just black belt.
One won the world championships every year.
Y'alls as a black belt.
Three years after he began training.
That's insane.
It's amazing.
Well,
he,
oh,
he had an incredible,
always had incredible flexibility.
You know,
that's one of the,
the,
the benefits that he's always had.
Dexterity and flexibility and his legs.
So instead of just being able to hold you with his arms,
he holds dudes with his legs swell.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Wec,
I guys who roll with them,
they always come back and I go his,
his ground game is so freaky because it was his legs.
He's on such another level.
Have you ever enrolled with them or no?
No.
Never have.
Here we go.
This is it.
Oh my goodness.
Oh boy.
Oh my.
What?
Eddie Bravo has got the freakiest legs.
You want to talk about Lego Sturdy?
Oh my goodness.
He can do the craziest shit with his legs.
Put them in places without things that put things that like other people have to
do what?
You have to grab your foot and put it in editing and just do it.
Like you can do it like a hand.
Damn.
His,
his flexibility is ridiculous.
That's cool.
In certain positions,
but it's weird.
It doesn't have like flexible hamster.
We got kids.
Here we go.
Jays,
opening out which strikes.
Okay.
This,
you know how Freddie Roach has worked with all these MMA tall BJ standing.
Look how tall he standing.
It's weird.
I don't think worried about getting taken down.
Look,
how tall are you standing?
Never seen him do that.
It's weird.
Weird.
Freddie Roach said Bj has the best box and he's ever seen for MMA guy.
Yeah,
look at this man.
Ooh,
nice left hook there by Bj.
Dude.
Bj looks really tall.
This is really strange.
Standing right there and the pocket does it.
I mean,
does he want to get taken down?
Dude,
he looks different than I've ever seen ever before.
So strange.
Wow.
Asleep.
She's looking,
he's putting price leg kick by by,
when you're that tall,
the leg kicks there all night.
So the tank towns,
right.
Take downs,
especially back and leg kicks are just that.
They're super tall on his tippy toes,
standing up straight.
Literally on his tippy toes.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
It's weird.
He's like,
he's changed his style.
Yeah.
Frank,
he's looking for a take down.
He gets it maybe wanting to go to the ground.
Maybe that's the only explanation.
As the feed on the hips,
Bj pushes him off
leg kicks by Frankie.
Wow.
This is crazy to watch.
Super interesting.
Yeah.
I feel like Bj wants him down there.
I'm excited that it's five rounds.
That's VJ wants to submit them.
Like he went right back to it.
You think so?
I do.
Why else would you be I tippy toes?
Inviting a take down.
I don't know if that's it.
I don't eat,
I believe.
And he's not kicking the get up either.
Izzy?
No.
Did you notice that work when he was throwing punches?
When he's hitting the,
uh,
the pads in the preview?
He was like standing straight up to it was weird.
Yeah.
I just thought it was because it was just fucking around,
right?
Yeah.
I thought so too.
But it's almost like he's changed his style a little bit.
I wonder if he brought in someone new to work with it.
He's got a philosophy behind it.
You'd have to write.
You can't just switch it up for no reason.
I don't know.
Maybe he had a vision.
Okay.
Maybe said,
come on down to the ground,
son.
I was in the ocean.
I had a vision.
I took our rock and went under the water then that now your sound.
No,
I'm trying to hasten Brazilian.
no,
no.
Roger.
So he's not trying to get out.
No,
no he's not.
But Frankie's not trying to let them up either.
It's weird friends to try to turn that corner back in.
The guard is trying to pass this butterfly and Jay has good luck with that.
Detail is scarred ridiculous guard to pass,
but you know,
it doesn't get a lot of triangles,
you know?
Definitely.
It
usually gets people's morale of the icon.
There's a lot of room to move while he's sweeps guys and takes their back.
Yeah,
he always gets their back.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
he's known for that.
Yup.
And locking guys up with one arm trapped.
He's a master at that one arm trapped.
Why?
He's got your back Frankie Passes Butterfly and be impressed.
Yeah.
Look at that.
So you could get up right there.
He could literally get up right then.
It seems like he doesn't want,
oh,
that was bad ass.
That's ensign.
Anyway.
Style old school.
You ever see that fight and Randy couture and send through some gangster kicks
off of his back from the butts scoot and then any arm barred Randy,
you.
That's Frankie trying to get back in there.
Back in there again.
The same.
Look at trying to get him to try to pass 800 cents in a new way.
A Samoan?
No,
he's trying to,
Jeff's big Japanese guy.
Is he a black guy?
Dops six foot seven.
You anyway.
Could be shifting.
He was just so thick.
He has to be something else besides job.
There's a lot of thick Japanese guys.
Look with Fujita switch.
Kick us.
Fuck it.
Easy.
Yeah.
So Toshi,
she's a fucking real thick dude.
Judo Champ.
Oh by the way,
don't call me.
She likes to be referred to us.
So Toshi,
oh,
really?
Learned that after two years of training with them.
What is Satoshi?
Was He,
she is first name,
is that what it is?
And Toshi is his last name.
Satoshi is his first name.
He,
she,
I dunno,
like sewing gay.
I don't know how it works.
He was just trying to explain Bj backup.
Let's say this upright again.
Straight up and just kind of there.
We're good.
Kick to the body by Frankie.
Nice switch.
Kick my Franklin to throw more low kicks.
There we go.
Checked one.
Great footwork.
Look at Frankie man.
I wish we could hear Mark Henry Right now.
So strange.
It is so aware.
So strange scene.
This style from him.
Light on his toes.
Very narrow stance.
Very now it's the most narrow I've ever seen in the UFC besides the kid who just
got knocked out who's six months,
right?
Strange.
No,
he's more narrow than that guy.
I don't know.
Like I was straight upright.
Yeah,
but Bj's got its feet practically touching each other.
Bj,
its feet are touching you and he's tippy toes.
Yeah.
Ooh,
nice left hook by Frankie.
Good combination.
Just what's going to happen tomorrow.
Kids.
He me in the gym on their tippy toes.
Probably Guaranteeing Copycat League,
man,
pee break.
Really interested to see how this plays out.
It's weird to get that first round of Frankie.
Frankie took them down 100% Frankie definitely landed more shots.
Bj was able to stifle him in the guard,
but Frankie kick the shit out of his legs.
I Frankie's landed more kicks take down,
controlled him on the ground.
Although he's trying to pass.
Didn't happen.
See how did,
let's see how if you're a judge when it goes to the ground,
you can't pass and no damage.
Yeah.
Bj gets no recognition for that.
Zero as a judge.
Yeah,
totally true.
Yeah.
It doesn't mean any,
I mean,
but defense nothing in a fight.
Yeah.
However,
I'm just saying,
right.
I know you're saying,
well,
you know what it really is,
man,
the system should be 30 points.
It shouldn't be a 10 point system.
You should really write a 30 point system and they should take into account
striking grappling submissions.
You know,
all those three things should be taken into account and that,
you know,
in the maybe 10 points each side,
like maybe one guy gets 10 points for grappling,
the other guy gets it's 10 points.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
At what point are they going to make the change?
I don't know.
I don't think in my life then.
I think so.
Yeah.
They're actually looking at some alternative scoring methods now they've,
they've discussed it.
I mean the UFC is very aware of it.
I would like to see them do something.
It can you see Mark Henry in the back yelling?
No,
I can't see.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's calling nonstop.
He wants like cakes.
Interesting fight man.
Interesting.
So far.
Let me see if Bj gets it.
His groove.
He's in good shape.
I'll tell you that man in this second round.
Still looking good.
Good overhand right with Frankie.
I like our,
Frankie does that goes to the single makes look,
he's going to struggle for it.
Disengages and Mark Henry's thing and they did it the first time BJ fought.
What would they do?
He's so good at defend that single leg.
They're just attempting it so Bj reacts so they can land a left hook.
Oh,
we tagged them in the right.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
If you're Bj though,
what are you telling them?
What's your corners?
Just like he just,
just walking them down.
It's interesting he's putting the pressure on,
but if I say interesting one more time,
I hit myself fucking mad at myself.
This fight is interesting.
It is the best way to put it is upright and just kind of walk in for kind of,
I don't know,
Eaton leg kicks and it's very odd.
Well he's checked a lot of them too though,
man.
Doing a great job.
I just don't care about that.
No,
no.
There's that right hand again by Frankie.
But BJ's walking them down,
man.
Walking him down,
walking them down.
You ready for my prediction?
Fourth Round.
Tko Frankie Edgar,
another take down right hand.
Right hand.
What makes you say that?
I just see some stuff.
That's what I think.
Wow.
What do I know that's a big prediction.
Doing it is the old tasks are,
you are bold of Brendan Schaub if you're anything your bowl like that.
A one sauce but Doug spicy
again,
the feed on the hips.
See I see this and I'm like,
damn,
that's so dope.
Bj can control in there and he can't pass everyone else.
Like damn be just getting his ass whooped.
The problem that weird.
He doesn't do anything offensive from his guard.
It's very rare.
I don't think he has a single arm bar victory from the guard in his career.
What he does is control guys,
stifled them,
sweeps them and then takes their back and choke something like [inaudible] all
his submissions.
What are they?
They're almost all rear naked choke.
You get your back.
Yeah.
Frankie landed a nice right hand.
They're in that weird Bj.
Such a BJJ
ridiculous skills and he really ruined nakeds guys like you're not seeing
armbars leg attacks.
He knows them 100% he knows all of them,
but you have your,
your kind of your niche that you do and you get comfortable with doing it and
then weird.
This is also weird for him to be sitting on his back like this.
I don't know.
Some guys just do that.
Like Marcella Garcia known for rear nakeds and gay teens.
Very rarely do you see Marcelo attempt an Armbar are though he did leg lock Rico
Rodriguez and the absolute crazy crazy.
We're ricoh is terrified of him.
Remember when he had Rico's back and Rico threw himself back on top of Marcello
tried.
Yeah.
250 pounds of Rico.
Slammed him.
Yeah.
Which is kind of fucked.
Um,
yeah.
I think it's weird,
man.
It just is.
It's so strange.
Like you,
you just,
you get good.
You probably have two moves in your back pocket that are your go tos.
You know the rest,
you know how to defend them,
but they're not your go tos.
Yeah.
There are certain guys that do that over and over.
Well they'll get Rhonda and our armbars.
Rhonda is arm bars are fucking ridiculous.
Like when she fought me ship Tate,
when they did the ultimate fighter together and said,
better get used to wiping your ass.
On the other hand,
she's telling her,
I'm going to arm bar you and what does she do?
Yeah.
Armbars are incredible.
[inaudible] it's crazy,
man.
Yeah.
When,
when someone has it like you,
you remember Paul Sas?
Oh yeah.
Really good triangles.
Like,
yeah,
great triangles.
He had something like nine triangle victories in a row.
Look at chocolate though.
My arms crossed just not into it.
Just like
it's probably not out and we sees chuck not out in the background.
If you fucked,
boy,
this is not the most exciting.
Yeah.
Bj's gotta be thinking he's two rounds in the hole here though.
No,
I mean Frankie on top of them two rounds in the hall.
Oh,
he's gonna sweep him.
we got blasted right there.
Lasted,
took some serious shots.
You see some ground and pound dexterity of his legs were ridiculous.
So few people can move around like that off their back with their legs.
But the bottom line is he's taking a beating man.
Frankie's on top of them elbow and the shit out of him here.
Yeah.
Oh Damn.
Frankie's relentless.
Frankie.
I hate seeing this.
Look at the hate.
Seen Bj Penn get beat up.
He is getting beat up too,
man.
Two rounds.
BJ's got to come on strong.
Look at this.
Oh my goodness.
BJ's getting rocked here with these elbows.
He's staying calm and everything.
See like here did you can,
I mean his level,
you can go for likes here and you can go for ankles.
He doesn't,
your options there.
He doesn't do it.
You know,
I'd like to see him in his corner.
Look at,
he's tired and I'd love to hear the corner.
Not this one.
The other one.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Ricardo made is in his corner too.
Great.
Give us a little volume there,
Jamie.
Please give us be djs all busted up a little.
His cheek.
He's taking big deep breaths now.
Two rounds in the hole for Frankie am I Ricardo?
When he was 17 at hands,
US walking around speed and everybody up at 17 and big.
Oh yeah.
Let me hear.
Let me hear this opponent.
Stay busy.
Did his face looks like fuck it.
I'm going to be honest.
That's a face of,
you know what?
Fuck this.
Don't worry about that
right now.
Just win this round.
That's,
that's not
just win this round.
He wasn't going to,
what should he say that?
Joe?
What can you say?
Well,
hey bro,
you are completely getting your ass kicked.
Let's try and revamp everything.
You can't just took a big deep breath too.
Well,
you know what he's got to do is he's got to keep the fight standing or he's got
to take Frankie down and get on top of him.
I mean,
if Bj gets on top,
his top game is nasty,
but he just can't hold him in his guard and put his feet on the hips like that.
Right.
Hand's going to do nothing.
Right hand is going to drop Bj and they seem to get t code
is getting,
this isn't as cool as it's changing now.
I'm super depressed.
Yeah,
that was a beating.
He was all,
oh right hand by Frankie.
Frankie's just more active,
more accurate,
more unpredictable and more successful.
So far.
Look at that.
Nice kick on the transition.
Looks like he's pulling away.
Boom lands that kick.
He does things like,
you know,
like he'll,
he'll shuffle in for the punches and then the second time he shuffles out,
he's throws a hard kick,
you know?
Or he looks like he's going to do what he just did and he goes for a takedown
mix.
That shit up so well it mixing it up.
Yeah.
And you think that's all his coach,
Huh?
A big part of it,
Huge part of it.
Very interesting now because when they hit myth,
they do it.
I'd love to watch those guys train to see.
I loved his fight with Allavara.
Charles,
all of your great fight.
Oliveira very underrated guy dude.
What happened in gray?
Maynard?
Uh,
it's,
he got knocked out by a couple different guys.
Nate Diaz knocked him out.
Um,
but you don't hear from him,
right?
You don't really hear that much lately.
What's a grid?
It's name that was going to fight for the title.
I'm just watching this.
I'm trying to pay attention while I'm watching this man.
Tj grant teacher grant knocked them out to them.
Their elbow standing elbow.
He's a few chaos and that was after frank and knocked him out.
So it was like finding a home man.
Beautiful combinations by Frankie.
The movement was just so good.
He's not there for a recoil.
Just ragdoll Bj to the ground there.
Crazy.
We just got to do something,
man.
He can't just lay here with him in his guard like he's been doing
okay.
Frankie.
Trying to pass again,
like Bj so comfortable in this position,
but it's a terrible position for him.
It's almost bad that he's that comfortable here because you're just losing the
fight can beat up.
But it's so weird cause you know he doesn't have an offensive guard.
He doesn't have a guard where he's attacks off his back,
tries to lock up triangles.
He's just impossible to pass until Frankie's half past here.
He's about to,
if he can clear that other foot,
we'll look.
Nope.
Awesome dexterity is and credit recovery.
It really is.
I love seeing it.
It is impressive.
But everyone else lives in this like this is the most bullshit.
[inaudible] smashing on more elbows,
more elbows,
boom,
boom.
How's Bj ob just cut bowed now.
How's Bj gonna go?
Always.
He's lightened him up.
He's like,
no mom.
That's what you get.
That's nasty.
Look at it.
It's going into his eye now.
I would be surprised if he hears corner.
You throw in the towel.
You already dealing with a legend like this.
We'll get that blood.
Oh Geez.
That's the bloodiest who've ever seen Bj.
Yes.
He doesn't really cut a lot when he's cutting a lot now.
Frankie keeps targeting that same spot with elbows and beaches.
Got Two more minutes of this to deal with.
Oh,
another one on the same spot.
All my goodness.
BJ's getting fucked up,
dude.
Herb Dean might stop.
This fight is to get to look at the cup.
Wow.
Uh Damn man.
But he just doesn't have an answer.
It does not have an answer.
And Frankie's been saying,
Oh God,
he's pounded on him.
He's going to mountain view.
He's got a crucifix or that fix and Bj and finished and like that.
They're just not going to happen.
Getting hit in the head.
Bang,
Bang.
Just don't just stop.
Other than that,
he's pounding a man.
What a Frankie submits them crazy.
What if he gets the mount?
Yeah.
Yup.
Oh my God.
He's crushed.
He's going back to this butterfly gardens doing nothing thing.
Oh elbow and other one.
He's getting worked.
This is crazy to watch.
This is not cool,
frank.
He's a monster man.
He is a monster.
Look at him just fucking for Roche's with these punches.
Elbows.
Herb is going to stop the fight,
man.
That's it.
Holy Shit.
Bj Penn.
Wow.
Frankie Edgar puts bi pan away.
Look at that.
That is crazy.
Wow.
That was a route that it was a three route was great for Frankie.
Amazing performance.
That's why he's a 10 to one favorite.
I would guess ten one favorite.
Yeah.
Well the opening line,
I mean,
I don't know what it was when the actual fight went down,
but man,
that's hard to watch our to watch.
Hard to watch.
It's crazy,
man.
They all go down,
They all go to one.
Does hate to tell you your favorite fighter that's going to happen to him one
day unless he gets out before that happens.
Yeah,
man,
I hope that we've seen the last of certain guys like GSP.
I don't want to see him go down.
I don't see Emerson go down like this.
Nope.
Yeah.
Do you think it's going to,
he's going to go down like this again.
You think Anderson's gonna wind up fighting again?
If I need someone else,
look at this boom,
boom.
Cause they're going to give him a fight.
Probably be in his favor.
He'll win that one and then you get some demon who is not going to be down like
that,
you know?
Would,
do you remember when he was coming out for the Wyman fight?
The second fight and he paused during his walk.
He was weird.
He got down on his knees.
He squatted.
It was just like sat there like almost like he's having a hard time breathing.
Trying to keep it together.
Collect himself.
Yeah.
Well just to fucking nerves man.
Knowing that you're about to go in there and against this dude is made out of
concrete.
No.
Tell me about
it.
Especially at heavyweight.
I feel like I'm not saying it but it is.
I am saying it's different heavyweights.
Different cause they can crack it with one shot because you're going in,
you just like,
all right,
well this guy is 265 pounds.
I literally,
if I make an error it's over and I'm going to get really,
really hurt.
So what have you.
It's just different man.
Like the nerves are different.
You're dealing with,
that's scary.
What's the guy that hit you the hardest you think hardest in my life.
You know,
everyone says you know,
like Roy Nelson who I got knocked out by hit me behind the ear.
So it wasn't that hard.
A same with Nogueira.
I would say
no,
that's the lightest I've ever been hidden.
Went out.
And the reason was I was sparring with Shane Carmen the week before and got
wobbled with a left hook or almost knocked out basically and then fought.
That's why that shut.
Wow.
Cause if you look Rothwell really doesn't hit me that hard.
He's,
I'm like flailing trying to put them away and he just like clips me in the back
of the air and I'd fall down.
I was rocked before that fight.
Wow.
That happens all the time.
Right.
All the time.
And at heavyweight to different bird.
Uh,
I would say who rocked me,
where I kept going would be probably Lavar Jonathan hit me with the upper cut
and it literally almost ripped my lips off.
Good Lord.
Who's a Banger,
Huh?
Yeah,
Bang.
Hit.
He was like put on this earth to knock bitches out.
He's a strong motherfucker.
Might have been a boring fight,
but it put a rustling clinic on his big ass.
Positive for steroids.
Yeah,
he did.
Well that's it.
Wrestling One oh one
Andy,
the Bj Penn career.
Man.
I think we've seen the,
the end right.
Well now I'm super depressed or him.
No,
it wasn't fun to watch.
Was it cool to watch?
I was on a high note.
I was hoping it would be a competitive fight that don't want to see that man.
That shit sucks.
Yeah,
it was a,
that was a whole lot of bulletproof coffee.
Bj Penn Law got his ass whooped.
Thing of that.
Yeah,
I know.
I got this.
I got to sleep tonight.
I want to zoom.
Manny did some weird stuff.
I need sleep.
I need sleep,
man.
Ah,
it's tough to watch.
When I was a kid,
um,
I uh,
watched Donald Curry,
who's a big fan of mine fight Mike Mccallum.
You remember Mike Mccallum,
the body snatcher?
No,
you don't remember him?
No.
Middleweight champion bad mother fucker.
And He,
Mike Mccallum hit Donald Curry with a left hook to the body and then a left hook
and knock Donald Curry the fuck out.
Donald Curry went out flat on his back and I was so depressed.
I just put on my fucking shoes and went running.
It was cold.
I was like,
I was living in Boston and ran down the street.
It's just running,
running.
I couldn't take it.
I was just so depressed.
And then I remembered the deciding at that moment,
I'm never going to get depressed when a fighter loses ever again.
I'm never going to invest in.
Let it affect you that way.
That would,
I can't,
I can't let it affect me like that.
I remember deciding that because I was so bombed out.
I took it.
So personally,
that happens to a lot of people.
It happens to me like when,
when I found out,
um,
or loss to get the main event against foot,
I wouldn't run
probably six miles.
I get super stressed out and sad about it because w that should have been me.
I didn't know what to do,
so I just went hit the gym running.
Let's talk about that because big foot's a weird situation man.
Cause big foot has a real issue.
Like he's got a tumor on his pituitary gland.
He has giantism gigantism I guess which made him um,
I mean they had to give him one point in time in his career is over 300 pounds
and you've cut the 65.
Yeah,
we used to cut down to 65.
It was fucking enormous when shredded.
Shredded when he fought our Lawsky when he fought fade or month.
Yeah.
Shred.
It was huge.
It was absolutely gigantic.
When he fought Arlovski,
he fought last game.
Oh yeah.
When they,
yeah.
They fought in Strikeforce or it might've been the lead XC.
It was a lead XC.
How did he do?
He won in a,
I think it was a controversial decision,
but it was a good fight really.
And he won.
It might've been decisioned but he won for sure.
Hmm.
Um,
so big get that cut.
My God,
it was pretty bad.
Crazy big foot.
Big Foot on those stuff though.
It does.
Just because he has an issue,
doesn't make it okay that he takes stuff because this,
this is why you want to make it fair.
Say,
all right.
[inaudible] you can take whatever he's taken.
Brian,
that would be fair to my problem with that of course,
is that when you,
um,
so you know,
ways to tell a guy and they can take hormones,
especially if you don't really need them.
Naturally.
If you,
your body's healthy,
you know you're going to fuck your whole endocrine system of your systems,
what's going on,
right?
Yes.
It's a responsible,
at the same time you're fighting a guy who was on different supplements to
enhance his fighting career,
then you are,
and you can't do anything about it.
Right.
And she has a path to do this.
Oh,
and they're fighting in Brazil.
Weird in Brazil,
bigfoot in Brazil or lossy.
This is not a gift.
This is a punishment.
Do you think that when he gets down there that,
I mean,
is it possible for big foot to fight clean?
That's the real question.
Nope,
not possible.
Not Possible.
But with his condition,
stuff like that.
Not Possible.
And he's been on his entire career and they want to get them off your ranking in
the top five.
Good luck.
So what is the reason to fight in Brazil?
So you think he's going to juice up?
I think so.
I'm wow.
Interesting.
I think so.
I Ellison if,
and this is what I would done if the UFC is said,
hey,
why don't you fight big foot in Brazil?
Say Listen,
I'll fight big foot.
No problem.
I want to fight him in Vegas,
California with the drug testing strict were all right.
He doesn't need this stuff.
That's fine.
That's fair game.
However I want it regulated.
I went random test to make sure he's not overdoing it because that's what guys
are doing.
Let's be real here man.
Fuck that noise.
Yeah.
Well what do you think about v torn now?
Cause vittores going to and he's gonna get a tight shot.
Weidman that ain't no picnic,
bro.
Whole him fighting Weidman.
No.
Coming off the sauce and fighting Weidman.
Have you seen the photos of Itar?
I've seen video of him lately.
No,
it does not look the same.
He does it.
He does not look the same.
It looks much smaller.
He's again,
probably get destroyed,
man.
Yeah.
It looks like you almost can make welterweight.
Dang.
Wow.
Yeah.
It takes a size nine shoe.
He's got small hands and feet.
Yeah.
It's not the biggest guy in the world.
He said a lot of broken hands because of that and his wife is at time.
Look at you.
Sorry man.
Flow.
Yeah,
I would,
the big foot stuff it.
It's tough,
man.
It's tough.
It's almost,
you almost want to say,
all right,
if you can't fight without taking this stuff,
she'll probably stop fighting.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not fair either.
We paint it even if he needs to stuff,
it's not fair because the other guys aren't on it.
That mean,
and that is the true not if you can't fight without it,
you really should stop fighting because a lot of the reasons why these people
need that stuff is because I had injuries or cheating or he used to do steroids.
He used to cheat whatever's.
The reason is if I fight bigfoot Silva and he's all juiced up on ever cocktail
he has in Brazil that I'm not on,
you punch me in the face and I suffered horrible brain trauma because you were
sauced up or how about I punched him as hard as I can.
Dude,
there's about two guys in this world who can take a Mark Hunt punch to the face.
Roy Nelson,
who he's fighting September and big foot Silva juiced up,
only juiced up and he's not taking his mate where his head is enormous.
So it probably helps them Howard juiced up.
It's helping him.
What's his kiss in the pocket with market?
No one,
this world.
So for those two guys,
I wonder if it did help them,
because if you,
if you know the whole story,
hunt fought big foot and they had this incredible war,
but then it turns out they tested big foot after the fight.
He was on testosterone replacement,
tested him before the fight.
He was at normal levels,
tested them after the fight Jack to the roof.
So put some stuff in their locker room,
maybe allege,
and he blamed his most.
Doctor blamed his doctor,
which is crazy.
It's doctor's gonna sue him.
We said he was gonna sue them.
I don't know who knows what the fuck happened,
but either way,
the point is illegally took stuff.
He definitely too much elevated testosterone and he definitely had a tremendous
ability to absorb punishment that he didn't have.
It didn't show in the Cormier fight or can we put them white cane,
put them away.
Like Cain lit him up and dropped him and put them away quick and their fight and
Mark Hunt hits harder than both of them combined.
There's no one in this heavyweight division that hits harder than Mark Hunt in
the world.
There's just not.
Isn't that fascinating that testosterone can do that for you?
It's crazy.
It's all you have to do is just go in there with a hyper elevated levels.
So take out the part that he has fucking giant Dantic TISM you know what I'm
saying?
That he's an absolute monster,
but now he can absorb punches.
Yeah,
and hit harder and better cardio.
Fuck.
If you're a,
if you do an EPO and everything,
are you assuming he's also doing that?
I don't know if you're open to this cocktail,
if you love your [inaudible],
whatever that is.
I don't do anything.
No,
I think you're on that is he had to bring him back to himself.
That is the question.
It's like,
Jeff,
how many guys are,
how many guys are on things?
If you,
if you're open to put these supplements in your body,
why wouldn't you be open to putting these other supplements here?
But of course not just like,
well,
I'll do this when I got to stay at this limit,
and they're like,
well,
if you do this,
you're really going to be a Badass.
No,
that's just ethically wrong.
If you're putting a needle in your ass,
what do you care if it's filled half way or full?
You know what I'm saying?
It's true.
Yeah.
That is true.
I mean,
a guy like chill,
I mean that's pretty much proves it.
You know,
chill had his reasons why he said that.
He took those first two supplements and then it turns out that they have this
incredibly detailed testing that Lorenzo pays for that's $45,000 per fighter and
they're taking this,
this is a crazy thing,
they're taking the drug,
they take the blood,
rather they'd take a test from you and then the guy has a direct chain of
custody.
So he's taking this flying with his blood to the place where they're testing it
and there he's like a notary.
Yeah.
Well it was basically like the guy carrying the fucking nuclear codes,
you know,
he's flying with it in his possession at all times,
gets to the lab so it's never left his possession.
And then they test it and you know,
they tested on shale got busted for all that stone EPO and HGH,
which the athletic commissions,
we're not testing for it because it's fucking expensive as shit.
Yeah.
If they had to look for fires getting paid eight grand,
eight and eight eight to win the show and it's cost $45,000 to test him.
Something is crazy.
That's why only the superstars in you taught cause you're,
you're paying the suicides so much money.
It's worth it to risk it.
Is it worth it now?
Cause now we just lost one of the biggest faces to the UFC who could talk people
into liking the UFC?
Yeah.
Is it though?
But it's worth it.
Well what is not the only one?
No,
it's like baseball.
When people freak out,
mark McGwire and Sammy Sosa,
you dumb fucks.
All the pitchers were on it.
So it's a fair game.
Lance Armstrong,
listen,
when he tested positive,
they have to go back to 15th place to find a guy who didn't test positive.
It's a level playing field.
If everyone's on it,
you fucks.
You know what I'm saying?
Sort of.
But it's chronic.
Well it's like,
especially in combat sports like well it's dangerous.
Well so's getting punched in the face,
you know,
that's pretty dangerous too.
Super Dangerous.
It keeps your career.
You can fight longer,
you can play longer.
You know,
you're not hitting a fast ball off your bat.
Speed slows down a lot of times in the major leagues.
But you can make 20 more million dollars in play for five years if you take some
stuff's signed.
Bron Ryan Braun,
Leo got busted and then ratted.
How to everyone say how he was against.
So that gave me an $144 million.
Went to fucking Costa Rico.
I was suspended.
Came back.
He's fine.
Yeah,
and I do it.
Why didn't you stay in deep and coach [inaudible] hundred 40 million in the
bank?
Everyone forgets.
He got a standing ovation when he went back to Milwaukee.
Really?
That guy,
he's back.
Hey guys.
Took a year off recuperating my body rich as shit.
And you stay,
you stay injury free.
Guaranteed.
Yeah,
he made it guaranteed.
So they don't take any of that away from you and you test positive for drugs and
robbing your friend.
Maybe like 10 millions.
Who gives a fuck?
That's so gross though,
isn't it?
That's,
you know,
that's an issue with change as well.
They're bringing in the federal guys,
so they're going to ask him questions.
Where'd you get the Epo?
Especially EPO.
That is a motherfucker.
That's a super,
super illegal thing.
Yeah,
you have that.
It's not good man EPO,
HGH.
Testosterone is normal.
Like you could find that EPO is tricky.
That's soup.
It's very dangerous.
I say nobody went to jail for taking steroids,
but you go to jail for lying to the feds.
Go to jail for lying on,
goes to jail for lying and you go to jail for selling it and mass distribution.
It's going to be really interesting to see what happens with Shell.
I mean,
I don't know where the fuck he got it from,
but Brian,
Stan was talking about it like you know that he had a conversation with shale.
He's like,
you better be forthcoming when they come to you and they ask you questions.
That is where you can't lie to them.
Listen,
if Brian Stan tells me something,
as far as the government goes,
I'm for sure he's listening because I'm definitely,
I'm calling a sir.
Yes sir.
Why are you calling me,
sir?
I'm really freaked out.
Can you just come back to my hotel room and talk to,
if I had to ask you,
talk me to sleep.
You're the inside guy here more than any of us.
Right.
If I had to ask you,
how many guys do you think,
what percentage guys are taking HGH?
There's a headline.
You'd be tomorrow.
Okay,
thanks.
Everyone's on shit.
I'm just going.
This is a fight.
Bigfoot only in Denver.
I'm just going to say some,
not some numbers and you just give me facial expressions that don't necessarily
deny.
Okay.
I'm 60% 70% wow.
We're going to stop there.
I don't want to,
it's amazing.
I don't even,
yeah,
like,
like when I thought Lavard,
John's for instance,
we went on the scales and we get off.
I turned my coach and he'll come on Bro.
Because obviously on stuff I just assumed like everyone's like bro,
he's jacked.
They're like,
yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
Well literally I just assume he's on shit.
I assume he's on HGH.
I assume he was on testosterone,
right?
It's just part of the game we play,
which is fucking insane.
Cause he hit me with like this 30% outbreak cut and I was like in La La land
almost ripped my fucking lips off 30%.
30%.
Cause he kind of went with it.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
That thing lands my jaws all shattered.
I'm fucking Kanye West style talk like slurping my dinner and shit.
What happened?
A Kanye West was a crotch shot I think.
Right?
And broke his jaw or some was it?
I just figure a gangster shot I made,
I assumed,
I assumed he wears like Gucci loafers and Shit.
This guy gangster.
I don't know.
Sports are crazy.
Listen,
this is,
it's just not the UFC.
We're talking about like the UFC prom.
This is everything.
And watch the NFL network.
The bottom of screen goes black.
Uh,
Jordan Dixon gets spent for enhancing performance enhancers.
It happens all the time,
but they don't make a big deal of it.
This like literally,
you don't hear about it.
You didn't hear balance sports center when no one gets tested more than combat
athletes,
but the,
they make such a big deal of it.
Well here's these other sports.
They don't because if you're better because of performance enhancing drugs,
you're better performing by,
you're better at hitting a ball.
You're better at throwing a ball.
You're better at,
you know,
doing sports,
but you're not better at beating the fuck at a person and causing damage to
their
brain and definitely taking years off their life.
Yeah,
we saw a rod last night in Vegas.
I'm a fan and I've always liked to have had a couple of gals with him.
Looks like he's having a good old time.
What the fuck?
This guy was at the bar to blonde die pieces who I was going to go up to and
kind of snag myself.
Good thing.
And I did it because they might away.
They'd be like away,
fuck out of here,
you know,
kind of money.
And he runs penis.
He's in the suite.
Oh,
I'm the seller.
I'm sorry,
I'm down below.
I'm down below in New York,
New York.
Literally in the subway.
I tell you,
if I was a rod out of a,
hey girls here,
my eyes are up here.
Look at me.
They did have the hungry eyes for big brown [inaudible].
Your girls were looking,
well,
let's talk about that.
There's a difference.
There's a difference between the dictate an athlete and a fighter when when
there's a bunch of athletes,
but then the fighter walks in the room that the stakes have been changed for
sure.
I have a male in the house.
Cool.
You hit a little white ball.
That's awesome.
I'll snap your fucking neck.
I wish I could say that.
I'll,
I'll snap your neck and then fucked his two girls you brought yet and you can't
do anything about it.
Brian.
I wish I could you tell us like feet or toes.
Shoes right now.
His toes curl it up and not the Boston red sox.
Motherfucker old snap your neck.
Take your girls.
Is there a single like sport that commands more respect in that night and close
and even boxing,
right clothes,
nice clothes.
Cause MMA people really can't even like what?
Well look at fucking Floyd Mayweather.
He's can compared to Ronda Rousey and everybody says Rhonda Rousey would beat
his ass in a street.
Beat the shit out of everyone.
I really did 100% she would look at that last fight.
I look at Port,
I'm not mad at Bj's girl.
She's very pretty.
But look at Port Bj,
man,
that is wrong.
And she looked at Bj.
I looked at his girl.
Oh man,
it's hard to watch,
man,
man.
I love that guy.
Hard to watch,
man.
You know?
And I just got to go home to his kids like that.
I mean that was something that he said when he fought Nick Diaz and I was
talking to him.
He's like,
I can't keep calling home to my children.
But then like this,
that's a beast,
man.
He's just scared of me.
You know?
Dan called me a once again.
I hate when I lose.
I hate being around my neighbors even link Dan cy,
man did they talk to me,
hate my neighbors,
but I walk in,
I'm like,
fuck sorry bro,
I can't stand my neighbors.
That's hilarious.
Really.
What's it about?
Because they're 50 and act like they're 30 and they party and do drugs and keep
me up when I'm in camp.
Oh No
guy knows who I am.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
come on Bro.
I just talked about snapping a rods.
Nick,
what do you think you'll do to you?
They're 50 and they party all night.
Party do drugs,
coke banging on the walls.
They yell at me when I Bang on the walls.
I'm moving out of there.
By the way though,
things are moving up and all.
My place is super nice dog.
My plates is Super Nice.
It's super nice,
but they're just whatever there,
I don't know.
They see you guys banging on the walls with each other.
I Bang on the walls and she yells at me.
All right,
I
hear you.
I'll turn it down.
Cheeto fingers.
I went over there.
I gave him a motivational talk.
It didn't work.
He gave him a motivational talk.
How they clean their life up and stop being Cheetos could get a job.
No,
I do though.
I'll do that.
49 95 I'll come to your house with cheeto fingers when you're in mid camp and
you're fucking training your ass off and you're constantly exhausted.
Constantly pushing it.
Do you look at this like,
you know like man,
there's,
there's only a certain amount of years I can do this.
No,
I don't just think once you start thinking that you're fucked,
I think you're right because they told me,
I,
I've heard about it.
I'm not gonna mention names.
Fellow heavyweight was going through camp recently and was like fuck this man,
this sucks.
Guess who?
Guess who doesn't say that in camp?
Me.
I'm like fuck man,
how can I,
I'm always,
I'm all I think about is what I did wrong.
I'm just like fuck I gotta do this.
I gotta do this,
I do this.
I constantly think how I can get better.
You are very self motivated so you know,
and I go,
I need someone to wake you up.
You get fuck no cause guess what?
Cause if you have
the have someone yell at you to motivate you,
make you successful,
someone's going to yell at you while you're fucking getting your ass whooped.
You don't want that.
You know what else is self motivated Brian Cowen.
That's right.
Listen gentlemen pretends to work out.
It does boxing going Chin ups,
hands getting fast,
man.
Life's crazy.
Runs up the hill and gets tired.
That's it guys.
I'm going to,
I'm going to go to bed.
Get up early.
Oh yeah.
What time are you working on?
Right into my meditation.
Read Nietzsche reteaching.
No,
no,
not as like the way it sounds.
It's a good thing to say to chicks and we trust the press.
Him Get into my horse stance.
It's a classic story.
First time I ever went to Brian's house,
he had like some fucking,
the catcher in the rye or some shit open on his coffee table.
I go,
you don't read that?
you're putting that out there.
When chicks come over to impress him.
He was like,
you're right.
I tell a story about that.
My standup just laying books around like I was going.
She was like really smart.
She went to Princeton.
I was like,
oh look,
Hemingway.
I Dunno.
I guess her read it so you when I'm not in,
are you reading the dictionary when I'm not on TV?
I read Hemingway trying to be God.
The things I picked up in a book,
something I've picked up in a book.
Kids cause I'm white.
W H I.
T do you ever read books about training?
About like,
like mental toughness?
A lot of people,
yeah,
I read a lot of like mental books,
a mental toughness.
I read a lot of like um,
military stuff really because if you can pitch it out,
military guys like navy seals,
what they go through in the mindframe they get in.
What we do is nothing compared to them.
Right.
You've got to think about the nerves,
the navy seals dealing with before they go into war and they talked about the
breathing technique and the mentality they have,
especially when they're going through like bootcamp and the navy seal selection,
which is insane because one,
I have like 99 makes the cut and seeing the guys who make it and the,
the guys who run it say they can always tell who's going to make it.
Cause I guess they talked to them,
interview them after each day and the one,
you know guys be like,
yeah man,
there's only three weeks left Africa.
If I can just get through these three weeks.
They see when they go acts of the room like he's fucked,
he's not going to make it.
Then another guy comes in the room and he's like,
I'm just trying to get through tomorrow man.
I'm just trying to get through tomorrow.
I literally take it one at a time.
I go,
just get through this drill and take the next drill.
Yeah,
and it's the same thing in fighting and that that's what I do.
I had never look at the grand scheme of things.
I never do.
Like I'll wake up and like I,
you got five round spine,
let's go,
let's do this first round and then I look at the state ground third,
fourth,
fifth.
That's interesting.
If you look at the grand scheme of like,
Oh man,
I got 12 weeks,
get ready for this fight,
and you seem about the 12 weeks,
what the fuck?
It's a lot of work,
man.
You're me overwhelmed.
You're not going to be focused at your best.
Breaking it down individually.
That's interesting,
but what about like the overall game?
Like if you look at your overall mixed martial arts game and trying to improve
and trying to compare all these things,
do you do like have like a,
an an an overall like assessment of like over six,
six weeks?
I would like to look like this for seven weeks in.
I would like to be at these numbers.
I'd like to be doing these rounds.
I'd like to be doing.
Do you have like,
like things match kids?
Cardio Cardio's never been a huge issue for me.
Like I was getting crazy shape.
I,
the one thing I do have like as a marker,
like a numerical marker is my resting heart rate.
If I'm above 40,
I freak out.
I'm usually around 37 38 when I'm phenomenal shape,
which beats Michael Phelps in Hussein bolt by the way.
Wow.
So when I'm like 37,
uh,
for Mitchell and I get down I think 36 37,
it's like the best I've ever been.
Jesus Christ.
Crazy,
right?
What gets your heart rate?
They're like,
what is like being a phenomenal shape man?
Like what is like the best thing that you do?
Like,
what,
what do you attribute that to?
Like what,
what kind of,
I don't know if I can put some one thing,
I'll just say just really like the tempo.
I sat nonstop and then I finished my week off by running on the track,
doing these long sprints where we monitor my heart rate.
So when it goes,
uh,
and so I'll end my heart rate be like one 88 soon as it gets down to one 40,
I'm running again.
Wow.
That's it.
That does it.
Yeah.
As soon as it gets down to 140140140,
that's not very low.
It's not very low.
No.
Yeah.
So you just keep swiping my confidence from though,
man.
Cause I'm fucking terrified and I,
and I'll,
I'll be honest,
I suffer a little bit from body issues too,
man,
because I'm not like Super Rib.
So that's why I'm always on a diet.
Like tomorrow I just don't buy it.
I'm going on a four day juicing cleanse.
I'm just going to drink a juice for four days.
I'm a feminist and had some dumb off at the airport like shit.
And I'm going to go on this four day Monday's Lens.
Yeah.
You Ate Wendy's?
Yeah,
I did.
First Time I've had fast food and probably eight years.
Yeah.
Sorry.
You're hungry and tired and he did some drinking this weekend.
They'll look crazy as humanity.
So when you say body issues,
like you feel where we take your shirt off inside the octagon,
like that kind of thing?
No,
not really.
Inside the AUC in like when I'm at a camp you,
it's rare.
You'll see me with like my shirt off,
which I'm,
I'm in.
I'm always in good.
We never wear clothes.
If I had your buddy.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
It's weird.
But I
cloth,
listen,
you talked to her,
Yani.
I'm sure there's something she doesn't like.
Unheard by.
Everyone suffers from it.
For me though,
it's just like,
like when you,
when,
uh,
you're looked at as an elite athlete,
I never want people to see me not in shape,
which I am in shape,
but I don't want people to see me like out of my peak.
But you see a guy like fade or like always had kind of like a little bit of a
gut,
you know,
always like he just didn't give a fuck.
He's just like whatever.
I'm going to say he had no ass.
Like just fuck.
It wasn't worried at all about,
I know it's different.
It's different.
I know.
Don't you wish you could be like that?
I guess.
Yeah.
Hell yeah I do.
Well what did you think?
Like maybe if he like thought the way he thinks I miss.
Is there a way to like emulate that sort of a mindset or program yourself like
that do culturally what is considered manly?
He also,
does it.
Know what I mean?
He also doesn't care.
Like I care how I look.
I'm very vain.
I like fast cars bad.
She itches and I live on the beach.
He lives in Russia,
wrestles Grizzly,
bears,
drinks fucking beer and fucking eats potatoes and has a gut hanging over his
belt and probably fucking Gucci.
Trued has fucking here hanging out of her armpits were both Russian Nate.
We're very different.
If you like had,
I don't think it has anything to do with being successful or not.
I think some of the biggest stars or no,
most successful people I know are very self conscious,
really big time in,
in MMA,
MMA,
NFL acting who and said please don't ever use acting with MMA.
I'm seeing stars though.
I'm saying like stop.
Please.
You're hurt my soul.
Put that together sir.
Um,
do you like when like,
like what athletes do you think in MMA or like real self conscious like that
certain ones.
You don't want to talk about it?
No,
not at all.
I'll tell you off there though.
Okay,
let's,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Uh,
this is another fucking fun fight companion,
man.
Man.
I want to talk a little while at the end.
Just alleviate some depressure mouse super down.
I was going to crash.
Brian's put sun the wall.
It wasn't,
and not trying for not putting,
not paid for it.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I mean it's not surprising but it Kinda is one.
You just don't want to see that shit.
Yeah.
All right folks.
When are we going to do this again?
When's the next,
when's the next one?
He's tell us.
Let's find out right now.
We'll find out when is the next one and we bring your boy Joe Diaz.
I would try that and then I want to laugh.
[inaudible] you guys make me laugh.
Let's find out what the script quick.
Brian.
Ella nose job.
Everybody's Day.
Hey guys.
Wednesday,
July 16th who's where where we are.
Is that you Betcha.
Donald Cerrone.
Jim Miller.
That's the next one.
A Wednesday night.
So Wednesday,
July 6th I'm,
I try real hard to get Joey Diaz in here.
Evan Dunham and a Edson Barboza
should be very exciting.
So,
uh,
all right,
dirty freaks.
We'll see you then.
Until then.
I'm Brian Cowen on Twitter.
B R y
a n c a l l e n N.
Brendan Schaub at s s C H.
A.
U B Aka Big Brown.
Could you get big brown on Twitter trying to find big browns.
True.
Please stop.
Send me Dick Pics.
How many people send you Dick Pics?
I probably get eight a week.
That's like,
I know you made it.
Do I check him out?
Yeah.
See Mia.
No,
West Palm.
We will see you with a real podcast tomorrow.
Until then,
much love and big kiss.
Bye Bye.